Yeah,
start getting started digging deep,
na na,
na,
na na.
Hey Brian Taylor,
somebody.
I watched it to rainy,
cozy Thursday.
Adorable.
They say on rainy days that people are a
little bit more devious.
So if you have an honor jar where you
gotta put like tips,
you know if you take a Bagel at the
office and you're supposed to put like a
dollar in there on rainy days.
Some people tend to not do that.
Like I'm not going to give it's raining.
I'm taking a break from being honest.
Really?
I wonder why rain does that.
I don't know what girls are always like.
It's funny.
It always reminds me of like past
girlfriends who would call and be like,
let's go fuck on our roof.
And I'm always like,
man God girls,
you're dating wet.
Good time.
God of guy there aren't that stable of
that low self esteem and daddy issues.
Kinda want to fuck on a roof.
I would tell you that when I take girls,
when I would take women's shopping back
in the day,
I ain't even happens with my wife.
Now I get a little horny because like
I'm the man who behind them.
I love that shit you're providing
whether at home with my wife when before
we got married,
she wanted these shoes and they were
fucking high heeled sneakers,
right?
I'm like some asshole named Ted calls
himself,
Christiane Newbie and now I've got to
pay $800 for a high heeled sandal.
Stanley.
I mean the amount of leather that goes
into a sandal and.
But they're the two women are sales
women and I'm the man.
I'm the man and I'm in A.
I think it wasn't a linen shirt and I
had a blazer on Ellen and blazer.
I spent too much money and I'm,
and I'm taking a girl on a little
weekend in Santa Barbara.
I'm the man,
the man probably not even working at the
time,
but whatever.
And she tries on these luby or whatever
the fuck Jimmy Choo's.
And she goes,
God,
they're so amazing.
And the woman brings out another pair
and she'd pitch,
Yep,
that bitches.
Right?
And she goes,
I can't decide.
Saleswoman goes,
get them both.
And she goes,
Oh my God,
I've never do that,
and I go,
if you want them both,
and she goes and she this bitch,
God bless her for my wife.
She hides behind their own hand and she
goes,
you're going to ruin me for other men.
And I was like,
get both the fucking get bulldog and
shoes.
I won't eat meat for the month,
but get the Vulcan you buy.
I'll buy that dress too.
I'm going to help you try it out in,
in the.
Basically what you're doing,
Brian,
is just perpetuating these gender
stereotypes that have been essentially
boxing people into these behavior
patterns for years.
It's not that they're natural,
it's totally cultural.
It's totally something that our society
has constructed.
It's a cultural context or construct or
other.
Sorry for being a provider.
No,
no,
no.
You're not.
Who you are is the patriarchy.
You are the patriarch.
You want to shatter the patriarchy.
I want to just break all the glass
ceilings.
Brian Rose Mcgowan,
who I think is sexy as all get out,
was on the cover of some
terrible magazine and she's in a leather
jacket.
Dress like a man.
Of course.
It's interesting how when you want to
shatter the patriarchy,
your dress pants,
I think she had gloves with the fingers
cut out.
Maybe she didn't,
but in my mind she did and she's hanging
onto some.
She's hanging.
She's looking like that.
Maybe a cigarette.
I romanced.
She's a bad bitch by the way.
Head is shaped,
not fucking around her head shaved and
the caption is she wants to shatter the
patriot.
I would say if I had a crack at that,
I would.
I would be the.
I turned into the biggest fucking
liberal in the world.
I'd be like,
you are 100 percent right and I'll do
it.
If I could cook you some food right now,
just lose your shirt,
an archer back and lick your lips after
we're done.
Dah,
Dah.
Isn't it funny how a really hot girl
back in the day get you to do anything?
Literally be like,
I have.
My joke is always like,
if,
if I don't care,
if it's a black guy there she is so hot
as fuck with shit.
She's so hot.
She's amazing.
She too crazy is.
I wish you to stopped working.
I'm just nodding and I would imagine.
I would imagine that she's probably.
I mean,
she stopped working there.
Hers Dad,
her dad was a coal leader.
Oh,
well she's fucked.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That.
I think she's possibly.
She quit acting hint,
Hollywood sexism.
I'm running away now.
Yeah.
This is right about the time where
runaway.
What am I supposed to do with that
information?
What is that?
Hollywood sexism.
You're so hot.
I remember meeting her after she'd done
doom generation at Erewhon my first year
in Los Angeles.
I was so into.
I was like,
uh,
hi.
I'm on mad TV.
I think that was the next thing I said.
Anything.
They try to get her attention.
She had no time for me at all,
but you know,
she was so you.
You enjoy privilege.
You have your house and all that stuff
because you have a bone structure.
That and a body that makes men sweat.
It's just my genetics.
I'm not trying to be A.
I'm not profiting off of a fortunate
role.
The dice plus her acting and also she
says,
I can't stand when men say smiled at me
and all that.
That was gross.
It's gross,
but.
But how about this?
How about looking at this way?
Hey,
sometimes we're so flummoxed by your
beauty and power that we want to say.
We'll just say anything.
Most of the time you can't even look at
her.
Then when you want to get to her,
you just want to say anything.
Just so she looks at you and it's
clumsy.
Yeah,
but maybe that's you,
but there's a lot of Dick wants.
I'm not clumsy women.
And they go,
uh hey,
why don't you smile?
You look better if you're smaller,
but it.
Come on,
man.
That's super common.
I consider it the same thing as a guy
who has a bad sense of humor,
right?
Yeah.
I have a friend.
You have friends that,
you know that guy,
but when you're a woman in a guy's doing
it to you,
it has the feeling of danger touch to
it.
I know.
I understand when a guy's pursuing a
woman and he's saying things like that
and he's kind of gross and clumsy.
We think of it as like a dude being
gross and clumsy to us,
but a guy being gross and clumsy to you
doesn't.
You don't feel like you might get raped.
Yeah.
I just feel like you'll feel a little
weird.
I know,
but like girls' a different world.
They're physically vulnerable.
Yeah.
That's never been any different.
Right.
Well,
it's never been any different,
but they never had the ability to
express themselves like there's never
been any opportunity to do,
you know,
put up a post on facebook about the way
you feel about something and have people
react to it.
Yeah.
I guess,
um,
I also think that there are some women
that embrace it and turn it into an
advantage.
I think people get into anything,
man.
They get into anything and everything.
They get into it.
You know,
I'm in a bit defines it,
defines them.
I'm into playing water polo hockey or
just water hockey fight.
I'm a fighter.
I know.
Well,
I was gonna say water polo and I'm like,
that's just too ridiculous.
Pocket water on it's hockey underwater.
I blamed the weed.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
People get into things and they might
get into activism and they might get
into the response they get from other
people because they embrace activism.
They that that's as much of an addiction
as anything else and sometimes those
addictions lead to really great work
because people do get addicted to the
adulation that they get from doing good
things,
so they continue to do good things and
it becomes their thing and letting
everyone know about how much good things
they're doing.
That's why it's so amazing when you find
out about someone who does things
quietly,
like someone would donate some money
quietly or helps people quietly and not
trying to get any attention whatsoever
for it.
You Go,
oh,
well that's real.
This is real altruism.
And so on.
Truman said that Truman said something
like,
I read a quote,
he said,
you'd be amazed at how much you can get
accomplished if you're not worried about
who gets the credit for it like that.
That's an important thing.
I think that's how charity should be
given.
I mean,
if you put your name on the territory
around the building,
you know?
Yeah.
There's.
I mean I guess it's as long as good
charity gets done.
Charity to me has always been a very
strange thing because it's.
It is super important.
You know that people help people out,
but when you find out how much of these
organizations actually spend the money
on the charity itself and how much of it
goes to the structure of the
organization,
it's crazy.
They're like what?
And nuts and they all lie about it.
They all lie about how much money it
actually because they just.
They do fancy accounting right?
To the Clinton Foundation is a good
example.
Bad something they don't know yet,
but that was pretty astonishing at how
much went to running the corporation and
how much it's going to be really
interesting to see.
How much the Clinton Foundation can
raise now that both of them have no
political influence anymore?
Well,
they still have influence.
Right,
but they just don't mention she.
They have no influence in how to move
American policy.
When she was secretary of state and her
husband was.
Do you think she'll do something like
run for senator again now?
I don't think she'll ever run for office
again.
I.
that's what I.
that's what her closest advisors say.
Oh,
you're just wore out.
I think so.
Fuck you.
It had to have.
I mean she didn't even want to go to
these places to be 70 and she's not a
healthy 70 either.
That was one of the other super annoying
things about this election is that if
you brought up her health,
you are sexist.
I,
I experienced that a couple of times.
People reacting,
like would you have brought up the fact
that she was fainting if she was a man
like fucking.
Of course whenever a 70 year old person
has just fainting,
fainting is really fucking bad.
People die from faint.
Yeah.
She almost died from fainting.
She banged her fucking head off the
ground in 2012 and Bill Clinton didn't
an interview,
said she was fucked up for six months.
Wow.
Yeah,
I paraphrase.
He didn't say it.
He said it that way though.
She was fucked up.
I'm telling you,
that bitch fell back out.
Cold cracks or head off the curb out my
dick,
out her mouth.
I cried on Monica tests for awhile.
Poor Monica.
What's she doing now?
Scraping shame off of her forever.
She did a round table,
our discussion and it was always
supportive of college students.
It's really funny.
She's talking and she's kind of talking
about her experience and some dude gets
up and goes,
well,
what's it like to be an attention whore
and have sex for money if something like
that,
like really hard and it was just this.
She was like,
wow,
I guess I helped myself up for this kind
of thing.
And she handled it well.
It wasn't that the HBO one.
I think so I remember that.
I was like,
why is this on Hbo?
What are they doing?
Like,
what is this?
She strikes me as a pretty cool person.
I don't know for sure and I think she's
attracted people.
Like,
I think it was a bummer that people made
so much.
Monomer dare bowl to you.
I don't mind a little.
Um,
I don't know man.
It's just wow.
Anti-Bullying has her first thing on her
twitter profile.
Wow.
Hmm.
Bullies in school,
bullied across the social scale.
Right.
So they don't believe the nerds.
They bully each other.
So if you're in there,
if you're,
if you're in a cool kid circle.
Apparently the bullies only bully.
That's what I read.
They bully each other because they know
each other.
Truly.
Definitely blue people in other social
circles to.
Although we're nerds bullying each
other.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
Bullying among groups,
but they don't really.
There's not a whole lot of cross
pollination.
But then again,
that's a dumb fucking know.
I read an article and I don't go to
schools and you know,
draw lines on that.
There were a lot of things that are hard
to figure out right there.
A lot of things were here.
Like you can draw these broad based
conclusions.
Like I went,
I read one article in New York Times
about how doctors are in the pockets of
pharmaceutical companies and the reps
are cheerleaders and I got a fucking
email from this guy who was a former
green beret friend of Tim Kennedy's and
he goes,
hey dude,
just say,
you know,
I sell drugs to doctors.
Nothing.
That's just not fucking true.
Like I'm just telling you like the
reality on the ground versus what you're
reading from the New York Times is so
diametrically opposed.
It's ridiculous.
Well,
in his circumstance,
but he's one guy working for one
pharmaceutical company.
Industry is gigantic.
It's huge and it's practices vary
widely,
especially depending upon what drugs
you're selling.
My wife's mom is a nurse and she used to
work with pharmaceutical companies.
They would take them out to a steak
dinner with them and they would
literally do everything they could to
get you to be like super high on that
company and it's what they do to gain
influence without actually paying you to
say shit to the patients.
You know,
like say if there's a company that you
like,
like this hat I'm wearing vortex optics,
nice people.
They make good binoculars,
right?
So if I,
I meet them and I know them and I talk
about them and I talk about them to
other people,
people perhaps we'll buy their stuff.
Well,
the same kind of shit happens in,
in the pharmaceutical world.
They use influence.
They become friends with these nurses.
They buy them nice dinners.
They take them out for drinks to pick up
the tab.
Wow.
We had a nice dinner.
I didn't have to pay anything.
It's all against the law now,
I believe.
Is it?
Yes.
Now I think that there are a lot of
strident laws are stringent laws,
whatever,
against sort of influence peddling and
getting gifts even in the form of any
kind of a trip,
any kind of a dinner.
A lot of that stuff is there's a wall
now beings.
What's the super good idea?
But people are so open to suggestion
that it should be absolutely illegal to
advertise drugs.
Well,
how about the fact that pharmaceutical
companies are bankrolling,
you know,
scientists,
food companies,
bankroll scientists to do research on,
you know,
on simple sugars and how your diet can
be made if 25 percent simple sugars,
you know,
according to our side is that I happen
to also be on the Coca Cola,
Nestle,
kraft payroll.
Are you talking about the 1950 studies
that I'm talking about now?
I'm talking about recently I'm talking
about the fact that the food and board
nutrition,
the food and nutrition board or whatever
the,
the bodies of government that set the
nutritional standards for what mothers
with dependent children eat,
what the military is,
what our school programs are.
Take a look at what their nutritional
guidelines are and take a look at the
corporations,
the people that are actually providing
the food.
Who has a huge interest in that?
Nestle kraft,
these companies that make billions,
millions of billions of dollars on
feeding our school children in public
schools,
right?
Is there really a statement that says 25
percent simple sugars.
If you read forks over knives by t dot
Colin Campbell,
he talks about the food and board
nutrition and he's a scientist.
He's a Vegan and board nutrition,
the food and nutrition board.
I think that's what called food
nutrition board,
but he,
I can't remember,
don't quote me exactly,
but you know,
he does a very good job of tracing the
genealogy here.
He's a Vegan,
so I don't really agree with him,
but he's,
he does an amazing job of kind of
showing you just exactly how the big
food companies are very influential.
Do you know how much their products into
the mouths and Belize of people who are
relying on the government to feed them
too much?
That infuriates vegans and he said,
well,
he's a Vegan,
so I don't really agree with them.
I was like,
well,
yeah,
I mean he's,
he's at scientology does an amazing job
though.
Uh,
and in that book of making the argument
for being healthier as a Vegan,
he talks about the China study where
study has been widely debunked.
Right.
You know,
the China study,
apparently they didn't do a good job of
pull up China study debunk so we can get
this totally accurate,
but I think essentially big part of his
book.
Yeah.
Well,
so it was a lot of parts of,
a lot of the ways people were a managing
the nutrition.
Well,
he doesn't know he didn't,
he never talked about things like
insulin and he doesn't come from.
It's not that scientific because you
know,
insulin is a big thing to talk about,
like how food reacts to kind of hormonal
response food has on your body.
What dietary cholesterol really does,
you know,
um,
all the combination,
the correct combination should be all
healthy thing,
breast and piece.
Trying to study.
Okay.
This is Chris Kresser who's actually
been on the podcast.
Huh?
I'm Bubba.
Bubba bomb.
The China study should be put the issue
to rest.
Please consider the information
presented here.
The methodologies.
Impressive.
Okay.
Scroll down.
Papa.
Papa Campbell recommends a Vegan Diet.
No animal based food at all.
He claimed that population studies
demonstrate that Vegan populations do
not suffer from the high incidence of
cardiovascular disease and cancer that
we in the West do with our diets heavy
on animal protein.
He also draws a correlation between,
if I remember correctly,
milk and juvenile diabetes.
I mean,
he draws all these correlations to even
chronic illnesses that manifest
themselves in children with meat and
dairy.
This is Chris' master John's,
um,
take on a says.
When I first started analyzing the
original China study data,
I had no intention of writing up an
actual critique of Campbell's much
lauded book.
Uh,
I am a data junkie numbers along with
the strawberries and Aubrey Hepburn
films.
Gay make me very happy girl.
It's girl.
Oh,
okay.
Mainly wanting to see myself a see for
myself how closely Campbell's claims
aligned with the data's he drew from,
if only to satisfy my own curiosity,
but after spending a solid month and a
half of reading,
graphing,
sticky noting and passing out a 3:00
AM from studious exhaustion.
And upon my copy of the Raw China state
study data,
I've decided that it's time to voice all
my criticisms and there are many,
uh,
okay,
bup,
Campbell.
Conveniently fist to mention the county
of tool toil in China.
The folks in two D,
Two l,
I 45 percent of their diet is fat,
134 grams of animal protein each day,
twice as much as the average American
and rarely ate vegetables or other
plants,
plant foods,
yet according to the and study.
And they were extremely healthy with low
rates of cancer and heart disease.
All right,
there you go.
He,
this is the problem,
the China study is that they only put in
stuff that backs up what they're saying.
Yeah.
And they'd confirmation bias.
Exactly.
So they didn't put in anything that is
contrary to that data.
And there's plenty of that.
There's plenty of that out there.
I really honestly believe that the two
co,
the real problem is the ideology because
the vegans are absolutely not able to
get over the idea that you should ever
eat or kill an animal should do no harm.
Right?
Well one day we're going to have this
factory made meat.
It's on the way.
I mean they're really close to being
able to do that in mass and when they do
that,
if they can get factory made meat and
factory made fat and if it turns out in
any way to actually be like the same
thing,
like you can eat it and it's healthy.
Vegans should eat it because it's better
for you.
Yes.
It's more nutrition.
I understand.
If you would think that you can get all
of your food from plants and you kind of
can,
you kind of can.
But there's been some real good
scientific critiques of the problem with
Vegan diets.
Yes.
That happened.
And,
and uh,
like a Charles pollock said he's been a
strength coach forever and he was on Tim
Ferriss' podcast and he said that they
said if you ever look what about Vegan
diets?
You've been strength training for 37
years and you know,
high level has got more gold medalists
under his,
you know,
toodle edge or whatever that he,
he's,
he's results driven guy.
Right,
right.
And that is so funny.
I said,
what do you think of Vegan?
Because he gained me.
He basically gave me nuts,
berries and some vegetables and he said,
after 37 years,
he goes,
I've never seen it.
I've never seen anybody on a vegetable
based diet actually be able to compete
in strength,
explosion,
those kinds of things to the level that
others have.
Vegan power lifter in the Olympics.
So that doesn't make any sense.
And then there's,
ah,
there's other vegans,
strong men.
I know there's some guy who's,
I'm sure.
I'm sure there are.
I'm just saying that,
you know,
according to polyclinic for the most
part,
his athletes,
he thinks have to eat meat because it
creates a more better for recovery
benefits,
strength better for all that stuff.
I'm sure that is dependent entirely on
the athlete because I think there's some
vegans that will tell you that they do a
Vegan diet and they feel better.
I know John Fitch did a Vegan diet for a
while,
but then he felt weak.
Just got to a point where you see,
this is one of the things that Chris
Kresser talked about on the podcast as
well,
that there's some initial positive
benefits from changing your diet to a
nutrient rich,
rich,
dense,
nutrient dense diet like a vegan diet as
opposed to the standard American diet.
The problem arises after years of living
like this where your body is just
depleted itself of the things that are
lacking in the Diet.
Now a smart vegan would tell you,
well,
that could be mitigated by better
planning of your meals and making sure
that you get all these healthy things.
That's true.
That is absolutely true.
And adding things like a.
what's that stuff from the green stuff
from the ocean allergy.
Yeah.
Allergy.
Which you can get [inaudible] from
allergy,
which is essentially sort of.
Look,
it's all life,
you know,
it's just we're deciding what's stupid.
If you really want to eat,
you should eat clams.
Clams are dumb as fuck.
He,
those stupid,
central nervous,
nothing.
I mean you might as well be eating
carrot.
It's like you could eat things.
We have this weird thing about stuff
that moves where you eat a venus fly
trap.
Or do you draw the line that I will also
donate animals.
Talk to.
I mean,
plants talk to each other.
Don't trees have conversations with.
They do.
I would love to have a Venus fly trap
salad.
Now that I'm thinking,
dude,
I tell you what,
man,
I went to there.
It's funny how some plants,
you know,
where there's shit in the.
They say you can almost eat anything in
the ocean.
Uh,
with scales and fins,
like whatever it is.
You can eat shrimp,
you can eat almost anything with their
certain like,
you know,
but when you go down,
I was in Tahiti,
which is considered the safest ocean to
swimming.
Swimming.
There's,
yeah,
there's nothing really poisons to have a
rockfish and there aren't even a sea
snakes.
I don't believe there aren't big sharks.
I mean it's like really,
really safe,
but there are always these poisonous
corals,
these little things.
I went scuba diving and the woman with
me,
uh,
just nicked her arm,
like the back of her arm on a,
on a piece of coral and man did that
thing.
It just,
it didn't swell up like big.
But if she was just like,
this really hurts and all she did was
just kind of brushed by.
And the first thing the guy told me he's
from,
from dad goes,
number one rule,
he said,
you look with your,
uh,
you touch with your eyes and you look
with your fingers.
How's that sound?
I was like,
don't touch anything if I let you touch
it,
that's my.
But otherwise please stay away from it.
And at one point were down there,
went down there and he starts clicking
his fingers under water.
This is like 80 feet under.
It's going like this.
I'm like,
what?
He's done and then nothing happens.
And he's like doing it toward this
choral thing.
So I think something's going to jump
out.
And then he takes a piece of coral,
picks it up and he digs into the ground
and out comes a what I thought was a
piece of rock.
It was a rockfish.
Whoa.
Which good luck.
Step on that.
See what happens.
Tell me how things work out for you.
Stick ahead.
Step out at rockfish and cover with
quills and shit.
Try not to go into shock by the way.
Especially 80 feet under.
That's not a good time.
Yeah.
But the problem is that you walk and it
looks exactly like a rock.
And if you're walking around in like a,
you know,
kind of you down there in the ocean or
you walk on that,
you can get one of those foot and phone
call dot.
Yeah.
And they don't really have an antivenom
for you.
You gotTa,
you gotTa let it work through your body
fucker.
They met.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's a rockfish,
but it will back rockfish.
Show him the other one.
There's one that looks like exactly like
a stone that was not the one was one
that literally looks like that right
there.
That bad.
Boy,
that's what I say.
Oh yeah,
that does look like a rock when his eyes
are closed.
Here's the weird thing,
man,
like what?
What the fuck information is being
passed from animal to animal and from
nature to animal that allows these
simple animals like a fish to just
change its body shape over time.
It's evolution.
It's exactly like um,
you know,
when you train a united a whale or you
train a bear.
So if you want to bear to get up on its
hind legs.
So what are they driven by?
They're driven by food,
right?
So every time a bear sits up,
you give them,
you click,
you click a thing and you give them a.
I'm not a bear trainer,
but you pick her train.
Yeah,
I mean honestly,
secretly,
apparently got some,
I got some hidden skills,
right?
Okay.
You go and you give it to him and then
when he gets up on his hind legs,
maybe you go,
you click the thing and you give them a
treat and then that's.
And,
and you give them a signal for when you
want that to happen and pretty soon you
will allow him to kind of make the
choice to go up.
And he knows that when I go up and my
hindquarters,
good things happen.
I get a,
I get a little treat,
right?
Say trend you don't train to bear by
going bad bear and hitting him on the
nose.
Good luck.
See what happens to your fucking face.
Right?
You do it,
you know,
you work with the animals and nature.
And I think evolution probably was the
same way.
The fish that looked a little bit more
like a rock,
you know,
a couple of those survived,
right?
Yeah.
Like when I was in bed,
I was in this uh,
because survival is a motherfucker,
right?
I listened to Ed and they had this
incredible,
uh,
it's where all the sea turtles would lay
their eggs and we would watch them
hatch.
And all these adorable little babies
would run down to the ocean everyday
like woo.
And all of us would be sitting there
going,
Yay.
And the kids were like,
look how cute they are.
And stuff like that and as I'm watching
them and there's so many of them,
I go,
there's so many.
And he goes,
there are and,
and my daughter's like,
he's so cute and so because you've got
to hold one before it went down there
and he looks at me and he goes,
1000 Sarah by one in 1000 that's just
cheese,
that's just food for the,
for the bay right now.
And he said,
I said,
what do you mean?
He goes,
they're just nothing but baby sharks
groupers and even big crabs waiting for
every single one of them and one in a
thousand turtles I going to live.
And then I whispered that to my
daughter.
So she understands what fucking life is
really about while you whispered in a
creepy way or real quick to assume that,
but you think they're cute.
It's got about 10,
10 minutes to look to is that water is
kind of fucked.
It's like they make food.
Hey my little food factories,
if they would make a thousand of them,
I mean how many do they make?
How many?
Probably 100 eggs.
So then there's like 100 of them in any
10 x 10 nests and that's one survives.
So when you see a big turtle,
you know,
and when you eat turtle soup,
remember that I don't eat turtle soup
or.
Well they do in Japan was in Hawaii and
uh,
the,
the big island,
the turtles just chill on the shore and
just hanging out there and signs saying
don't starve them.
So cool.
Yeah,
it was at a resort and people just walk
by them.
It really was to be included,
the turtles,
but it's just,
you're looking at this crazy life form.
You're so used to it that it just seems
normal.
Oh,
there's a turtle.
Oh look,
it's a turtle.
But then if you take yourself out of
that context of familiarity and you,
you,
you just,
just get a look at what that life form
is like.
That thing is a shield on its back and
it sucks.
It's grotty into this hard case and it's
swimming around in the ocean.
It's living out there going under and
then it comes up on the beach too.
It does whatever the fuck it was when we
were done scuba diving,
we saw this pot of beautiful little
dolphins,
bottlenose porpoises,
but the kind of dolphins,
a little gray ones you see that jump out
of the that you swim with and it was a
group of them and they swim with the
boat.
They live,
they know you're there and they'll swim
with you and they swim at the boat and
they jump out of the air and they flip
and they're literally showing off here.
There's no question about it.
Right.
And I said to the guy,
I wish we'd seen them when we're scuba
diving.
I could've played with one and he said,
you would never see them when you're
scuba diving.
I see.
What do you mean?
They're right there.
And he said,
they don't like the bubbles.
They wouldn't come near you.
And it freaked me out.
I don't know.
And he went,
by the way,
he was French and he said it in French,
but I like being theatrical because he
was really creepy and on the back of my
neck.
Oh,
it was breathing and he was wearing.
What the fuck was he doing behind me?
I don't know.
I was drunk.
I drank too much.
I know.
No was to hate him and I just wanted to
come clean to Tahiti.
Dude,
we were in Tahiti.
It's not gave us to Haiti and it's not
safe.
I'm not looking him in the face to heat.
We just get crazy and said.
And he was like new,
small,
new small.
Won't beat the hood.
Got It.
Have you ever seen a crocodile turtle?
No,
but I'd like to bring that up.
They just chew them up really like
nothing.
They just to read through the terrific.
Oh,
crocodiles are fucking horrific.
They can,
they have acid in their stomach.
They can break down fucking anything.
Anything.
License plates.
Horns.
I'm going to eat.
Look at this.
Well,
this,
this is an alligator.
This isn't even a big one,
but this is good enough.
I didn't find one.
There's a,
there's a video of a crock.
They look at the right there,
right there.
Were there,
there,
third down,
third down on a table.
And alligators.
They're incredible.
Um,
well guess what?
It's turtles fucks Ville.
Well now hold on.
It doesn't seem like it's going to break
through that shell though.
No.
This one,
it seems like it's a little too small.
The one that I saw was a crocodile and
so it was a really big animal and
mashing this turtle,
that's a waiting game.
He's not strong enough to do it.
He's too stupid to.
He used to run to run it fairly slathers
away.
Look at it.
Oh my God.
What a creepy animal that just live big
ass reptile.
Fuck him.
He's going to swallow them whole.
Nah,
no,
Nah.
Is a wash.
He's not getting this one.
Definitely choke on that thing.
Yeah.
He's not getting this one is so geared
trying.
Yeah,
look it.
It's got no brain.
Look at that as a brand.
The alligator,
you know,
when you hunt for alligators,
you know what you have to do.
See that thing right behind their head.
He dressed up like a sweet shoot it
where like you see his,
his,
uh,
his eyeballs back up a little bit.
The plate behind his head.
It's like right behind his eyeballs.
I would go for right there.
Right at that spot.
Right there.
That's where you want to work crocodile.
Dundee stabbed the fucker when it
grabbed the girl.
That fucking happened.
Yup.
Does it?
They're so creepy.
I read that a guy got bit by a
crocodile,
not a big one,
and he reached behind the clock.
I stuck his hand up the things ass and
pulled whatever he could out and the
crocodile let go of him.
What?
I'll say it again.
He reached into his ass.
He reached into a task.
Now I don't know if that's possible.
Let's just map.
This is the world where it crushes the
shells.
Oh,
is that an alligator?
It looks like it looks like an
alligator.
That looks like a crock.
Oh yeah.
This one.
I believe they have the strongest bite.
The American alligator to smashing right
through it.
I hope that's not the turtle.
It is.
Make that noise before.
No,
but look at the blood.
That's the noise.
The turtles making that noise because
it's killing it.
Holy Shit.
This is exactly.
The video is talking about looking at
how are you going to eat the shell and
everything.
Look at it just keeps crushing.
What a monster.
This thing is.
Come on Jamie.
Jamie fucked up.
I don't want to hear sounds of turtles
being tortured,
but look,
I don't,
but I do.
Look at how it just crushing it's body
sane.
That didn't look at his eyes.
Just stupid fucking eating machine.
Yep.
A dinosaur.
That's a straight up dinosaur,
huh?
I mean we'd say stupid,
but you know,
there's obviously the capacity for being
even interested in anything.
The giant Crocs I guess lose their teeth
by the time they're like 40,
I'm sure and I'm sure that things are
going to lose his teeth to title they
fight.
Other crux,
they get a giant mouth fights.
It's interesting.
We mean the thing serves its purpose.
I mean there really is no need for books
really is.
It's not.
It's not excited by intellectual
discourse.
It's not here to diffusion of innovation
as a hunter would say.
It's not.
It's a movement of ideas here for any of
that.
It's here for fucking up everything that
he can eat.
Yeah.
That's what it's there for.
It's because people and things and
turtles like to fuck.
And if they like to fuck,
they make too many of them.
So we have to have around crocodiles and
alligators.
Yeah.
And Lions and everything else that eats
shit driven by one driven by certain
things.
We're so we're so detached from that
world I think.
I think that's um,
that's the function and the sort of,
the biggest difference between what it
is to be human.
There's a fundamental difference,
you know,
human beings who was thinking about how
we create beauty for its own sake,
what,
why,
you know,
a lot of times even at our own expense
at that famous,
whether it's true or not,
the legend of Michelangelo Painting the
Sistine Chapel and going blind because
the paint was in his eyes inspired by
something bigger than himself.
Paint above them.
He definitely,
I mean,
that's like the historical record is now
part of that.
This,
you know,
people just went blind,
blamed it on the paint when,
well,
he was on his back for a long time,
but they said,
you know,
sometimes,
well,
human beings have this need to be
immortal,
right?
We want to leave a mark,
whether it's to our children or through
our work.
That's a very deep,
deep drive.
But I don't like as I get older,
I don't like just,
you know,
breaking it down to simple constructs
like that.
Maybe because I'm a romantic,
I'd rather believe that we have
something inherent in us that is a,
this just,
I don't know what it is.
Maybe an inherent inspiration,
a nostalgia to create something that's
much bigger than ourselves.
That's,
that,
that moves people to tears,
brings them to their knees,
uh,
drops their jaw and all that stuff.
Is that,
that's what I think is fascinating.
Like I was,
I'm writing then back then it was the
only way to leave that mark to.
You have to understand the context of
the time.
Yes.
If you think about today,
you could write a book,
you could make a movie,
you could fucking do a comedy show,
you could do this,
you could do with that.
You.
There's so many different avenues,
but I'm talking also about.
I wonder if animals feel like,
for example,
when you listen to a beautiful piece of
music,
right,
and you're driving down the road and you
have.
Have you ever had that feeling where you
like you go.
It's a feeling of inspiration,
right?
So you kind of feel really sad,
really happy.
You want.
I love everybody.
You know,
that feeling of wonder.
I wonder if animals have anything like
that.
There's no need for it.
They don't have communication,
so if you don't have communication,
they probably don't have these crazy
weird fluctuations of their intent and
their,
their lusts and desires and their,
their path is probably much,
much straighter and trauma.
Yeah.
It a lot of ways.
I don't know,
man,
a lot of intellectual masturbation,
I guess the end of the day,
but it just seems like I'm the only
things that have that capacity are
humans and maybe dolphins and orcas and
whales.
Whales,
yeah.
They seem to have really strong bonds
with their family and they do
communicate that.
Telecom,
is that how you say his name,
the one that died in San Diego?
Was it a guy or girl?
Good girl.
Oh yeah,
there was a guy who was the guy.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that will from black fish is dead now.
Thirty five years old.
They lived to be 80 plus and the wild
folks find that acceptable.
That's a.
that's a living thing that is probably
as smart as your fucking neighbor and
it's locked in a swimming tank in San
Diego and it's fucked and now it's dead
and that thing bread in the wild.
It made.
I don't remember many slave
babies,
but that's essentially what it made.
A bunch of slaves.
It's fucked.
It's seaworld.
No longer doing that.
Now.
They should be in jail.
They should be arrested.
You,
you're.
You're slaving intelligent beings.
They just can't talk to you in a way
that you should understand.
You can understand.
Right?
So you're profiting off of enslaving
intelligent beings and making them do
flips.
This is a 1950.
We know what the fuck a dolphin is.
We know what an Orca.
It's,
you know,
if you.
If you are a person that is breeding
those things in captivity,
keeping them in swimming pools.
It's crazy that it's legal.
What's funny is I didn't know anything I
never thought about that,
didn't know that,
didn't think that would have told you.
They were probably very happy until
blackfish came out,
which I didn't even see because I didn't
want to say it.
I've had this kid filled demars on my
podcast a couple times now and he's from
marine land.
He.
He got fired from Greenland and he has
gone like way of his way to expo.
It's in Canada to expose all of these
violations of animal welfare and animal
safety and all the fucking horrible
practices that this place now they're
being brought up on charges.
They were just recently brought up on
more charges.
Like He.
He tweeted something about it just a
couple of days ago,
marine brought up on charges,
but he was a walrus trainer there,
this named smooshy and he developed this
really close bond with this walrus that
he was training,
but he was like,
this place is fucked.
Like they don't give a shit about these
things.
They don't give a shit about these
animals.
And he's like,
and they were getting their dolphins and
their orchestra.
They're getting them from these Russian
ships that brokers get them from China.
Yeah,
we're inland faces.
Six new animal cruelty charges.
Yeah.
Fuck up close.
Well,
the one for me,
seeing how small the tank was for killer
whale to swimming,
the charges are related to the treatment
of an elk or red deer in a fallow deer.
What?
They have tears roaming around there.
Whatever your theme,
less sympathetic to make smart.
Well,
the whole thing is just.
It's insane that it is legal to keep
dolphins and orcas captive is insane and
whales too,
but obviously we are the two big.
It's insane.
It's.
They're so fucking smart,
man.
If you've seen the image of a Dolphin's
brain right next to a human's brain,
their brains are bigger than ours,
like we don't know.
We have such a clearly defined standard
for what we accept as intelligence.
Send me an email.
Where's your house?
You know,
uh,
how much do you make a year?
What do you do for a living?
If you're not,
if you don't have any of those things,
you're fucking barbarian.
You're,
you're,
you're not really a person.
Like,
look at that dolphin brain.
So he went to look at the 10 til is
different,
right?
Yeah,
but it's,
it's not.
It's all within the confines of what we
think of a civilization will.
All those things are meaningless to a
dolphin.
They don't have fingers.
They don't need them.
They don't pick things there.
Moved to three
d space in this warm water.
They have free food everywhere.
They don't have any need for money.
There's no need for clothes.
So where does the mind go?
Then?
We'll see as the mind goes to comradery
or culture or songs,
those dolphin songs that we don't
understand.
What the fuck they are.
Who knows?
I mean,
maybe that's where their thought goes,
but what we do know is there's a lot of
thinking going on.
This is not a piece of salary.
Yeah.
You know,
this is not an animal that should be
kept in a,
in a pool.
No,
it's not even like animals that we
really like it,
like a dog.
This is way smarter than me.
This is an animal that is used to jump
through hoops literally and for fish and
to do twirls and stuff and to pull you
along as you ride them.
Right?
Or want to scan them.
And if you take that out of the
equation,
that seems to me to be where seaworld
makes a lot of their money.
I've been to that show you.
Right.
So,
um,
and when I was watching that show and my
kids were all excited,
I never thought in any way it was
cruelty to the animal.
I just didn't know.
It doesn't look like it.
Right.
And so,
uh,
but,
but I think we could do without.
We could probably do without though.
They say it raises awareness and stuff
like that.
We'd probably do without bullshit
documentaries,
raise awareness,
and that's why their business is down by
a massive,
massive amount.
That's why they're hurting.
Oh,
well yeah.
There's.
The stock didn't really suffer at first.
Did you see that after black fish stocks
stayed pretty strong for how long?
Up?
For about a year.
Maybe more.
Their stock was not.
It didn't take a hit,
and then I guess as time went on,
well,
people hear about it on the Internet.
They start exchanging information,
start reading about things that they're
doing there.
Start reading about how long the animals
live in the wild versus how long they
live in captivity.
You see the dorsal fin that flops over
because they.
They never have to deal with wave,
so it atrophies really ugly.
Other dorsal fin becomes like a limp
Dick.
This flood is for.
It's for.
It's for steering through the water,
for handling waves and correcting your
path,
your path.
So for them outside in the wild,
it's rigid and powerful,
but in this pool where there's no waves,
it never gets used,
so it flops over.
Damn.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen that show showing an
image of it?
It's fucking great.
I didn't see that.
I couldn't watch the documentary.
I was afraid it would make me.
It's like a guy doesn't.
He's not allowed to use his arm,
so his one arm that just withers and the
other arm is big.
Yeah.
I don't have any more to allow them.
Oh fuck.
Sales doorbells just flops over.
See how one in the wild as like this big
size of that rudder.
Yeah.
Well they need it.
You know what I mean?
They're dealing with waves.
You imagine it's ugly man.
It's an ugly practice and as much as
those things do,
jump up on that platform and do get that
fish and do,
do the flips and make everybody happy.
It's fucked up.
And also I feel like if they really to
have a relationship with these orcas,
the correct way to do it would be to
have some sort of a meeting ground where
they meet these orchids and they get
them to do things for fish.
They get them to do tricks.
I'll start.
So like an open area of the ocean can go
wherever the fuck they want,
but if they want to come back around and
hang out,
that makes sense.
You know,
like maybe we'll get to do an orchid
show today,
but maybe you won't.
But you know that having them in
captivity and lifting up a cage and they
swim through and all that horseshit.
Yeah.
That's where it's fucked.
Does it?
Everything in the ocean fear the Orca.
I think pretty much they have to.
Even whites,
right?
Yeah.
They fuck great whites up.
They eat them because they said that
they played,
I think Paul de Gelder who lost his arm
and his hand in his leg to a bull shark
and Sydney Bay City Bay doing routine
stuff.
And um,
is he the guy that has a carbon fiber
right now?
Yeah.
And he's,
he's,
he's pretty cool.
He squeezed my hand hurt.
He couldn't really squeeze.
It's a $90,000
fake hand.
Well,
yeah.
And he squeezed it.
He was an Australian navy seal and it
feels good to finger.
Somebody can't write.
I don't know.
Maybe that guy who was my scuba
instructor will tell you.
I mean,
it just seems like.
I guarantee I guaran fucking tee.
He's tried it,
I think at one point.
Yeah,
for sure.
He's a good looking guy and there's
obviously girls are like,
well,
let's give it a shot.
Of course.
What?
You're not gonna you're not gonna play
with the mechanical hand.
How long do for.
Do you think they have those Luke
skywalker arms?
Remember when Luke Skywalker got that
new alarm and it was dope,
like pretty immediately.
All I know is I've always been self
conscious of my left arm.
Why?
Because I feel it's a little skinny.
Especially in using your right.
My right is fucking ridiculous.
Look at that shit.
But why is it different in my mind today
is I have weird shit about my body.
I have.
I have a weird thing about this side of
my body,
my left side and serious.
I swear to God.
Here it is.
The Star Wars.
I remember this so well.
He could feel the nerves.
Yeah.
And you had to close it off.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
man,
you know,
it was a big consultant on these movies
who,
Joseph Campbell.
Really?
He makes sense.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
For all the heroes journey,
look at that.
Yeah,
well that's common or what you're seeing
right there.
Oh yeah,
it's coming.
It's 50 years from now or eight years
from now,
whatever it is.
The real problem is going to be when are
we just going to be like a spinal cord
hooked up to all this stuff.
Just going to keep replacing shit.
Like I've been to a lot of people that
have faked things like fake knees and
fake shoulders and fake hips,
but we like to come back and a lot of
ways to,
to the simplicity and the organic,
you know,
like look at how the food movement,
we like to eat on wood.
Nothing's really ever replaced.
The feel of wood or courts or for.
Yes,
true.
Synthetic synthetics have a limit.
What was that thing about?
They were talking about something
fascinating about like there's a point
where robots.
Oh yeah,
the guy who created a coo.
I scuba dive with a guy who is the owner
of I robot,
right?
So they may call the,
he builds robots,
went to mit and stuff like that.
Really Smart Guy and said,
and I said,
talk to me about sexual robots.
And they said,
well of course I did because I like to
get deep.
Right?
He's this really smart guy.
And I'm like,
what about,
what about things that could fuck bro.
I know you got something to vacuum my
floor.
You got some,
but my dick.
You got,
you got something for my Dick.
Yeah,
there's a little tiny drones are cute.
it's cute.
I got to come.
I'm looking to come in.
Drone drove and drunk and I said,
what about cause you know,
it's coming.
I said,
what about fucking a robot?
And he said,
there's this,
there's this weird situation where we
call it the,
uh,
I think it was the revulsion factor or
the,
the repulsive factor.
So human beings,
you can get something really close and
people will fuck it.
Like you can have like just a pocket
pussy,
right?
A Guy I'll carry around just like a,
like a flashlight or a gel pussy and
bang it and in the bathroom and his
office break right while he watches porn
on his phone,
whatever it might be,
but there's something about a robot when
you try to get it really human.
He apparently from their research,
and I don't,
I'm not saying this guy comes up with,
he's working on sexual robots,
but like he said that you see there's
something about creating a robot that's
so human like,
but there's just something missing like
the expression in the eyes or whatever
and it gets to a point where you get it.
When you get it as real as possible,
like,
as real,
as real as possible.
It people will fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
And then when it gets so real,
they'll go up.
It's not know you're trying to be too
human.
Oh,
hold on.
You're trying to make eyes that don't.
They're not.
Something's missing.
Something's weird here.
Something and,
and it.
And it apparently shuts people off right
away.
It makes sense.
It just would freak you out.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
it's not a person,
but it's so close.
It's so close.
Yeah.
Why?
Why would you get hard for that?
That would be too weird.
Well,
you would feel so strange if you fucked
a robot for.
You'd feel it.
Any moment.
That thing could kill you.
Nobody ever.
Exactly clear them and more importantly
for choking you.
But way more importantly is that more
importantly,
if you got lucky,
you got the lady thinking about fighting
for my life against this robot.
I'm trying to fuck.
Why don't we get low when we start
talking about dirty shit.
I Dunno why to talk like that when they
want to be sexy.
Yeah.
There's like things that don't work,
but people do.
Like when you talk like this,
it's scary.
No,
it's not because that's not scary.
Like we've got it in our head.
That's scary.
But he boys looking for company.
Oh,
one 800 hot slowed.
I just liked that.
You immediately,
before we got to the factor that was a
girl when I like strawberries and what
was the other thing?
Oh,
something else.
First thing I did,
I immediately.
Yeah,
there's like certain signals that gay
guys will just throw up.
We'll know.
Like,
I'm a huge share fan.
Koto a Barbara streisand concert.
Gay is everywhere.
Yeah,
well they have,
you know,
it's one of the fun things I guess about
being gay.
So they have these uh,
female diva like idols that they
worship,
you know,
like shares a giant one in a billion
wicked thoughts.
They,
uh,
it's a really great book written by two
neuroscientists.
Oh,
you're telling me about that.
And,
and the average gay penis is a half
inch,
half inch longer than the average
straight pick penis and also the gay
brain apparently.
So,
so the gay brain.
I know,
I know I'm,
I'm,
first of all,
I'm not affects at this time on the real
scientist.
I'm not a fixed that you can take
scientist out of that,
that phrase,
but,
but what they found is that.
So why,
why,
why all these men who love Barbra
streisand,
why are they mostly gay?
Why?
Right.
And there are,
there are,
according to the research that I've done
in my backyard and on this book,
which is a great book,
uh,
and,
and I got it from,
I think it was gad sad maybe who was
recommending or talking about it,
but no,
it was Jordan Peterson,
so I read it,
but you know,
there are,
there are fundamental differences with
the way the,
the man whose gaze brain reacts to
certain things in relation to how the
average straight brain works reacts to
certain things.
This is kind of dicey situation and
territory because we don't know all the
facts,
but according to all the other research,
why is the gay penis a half inch longer?
Apparently it may have to do with the
Androgens,
the presence of more androgens I guess,
or a type more testosterone,
whatever it is in the uterus at a
certain point in time,
which may be why some people are born
gay and other people because it is
something you're born with and some
people are born straight and we're
drawing.
I'm being very binary.
Do you think though that it is possible
to be born straight,
but somewhere along your,
along the lines of your life become
attracted to this,
to the same sex and be gay?
I don't know.
Maybe I have no idea.
Just trying to pretend he doesn't.
No,
no.
I've been trying to say I don't know a
lot more ever since trump won because I
was very.
I was like,
let me tell you another reason.
He's not going to win guys,
because some people think that you can
learn gay behavior,
which is why it was so.
Some people are really terrified of of
gay people.
I think they're going to get turned gay.
Those people are like,
they might be.
They might be.
I can be around guys fucking all the
time.
You yes you,
but you're not an easily influenced guy
in that regard.
Like there was some fucking people out
there that you just know you could talk
into sucking your Dick if you were gay.
You just know that it might not be gay.
Like shop for example.
Oh sorry.
So how dare.
Sorry,
he's not here to defend it.
I feel like there's,
there's a certain percentage of the
population that could be shifted around.
They could.
They'll dell adopt an English accent if
they live in England for a week.
You're sure.
Like there's a certain percentage.
Peer pressure.
Yeah,
they'll suck a dick for peer to turn gay
to have better friends.
So let me ask you this.
I believe that you can't say that better
friends.
I really believe that's true and I don't
think there's anything wrong with it
necessarily because why is that any
better than being or worse rather than
being indoctrinated into a certain
school of music.
Like will you all listening to tribe,
right?
Yeah.
Why is it any different than a religion
or anything else that people get super
sucked into and they altered their
behavior?
I had one guy,
I had one gay feeling like feeling a
feeling if I'm really honest with
myself,
like flashdance what a feeling,
how it was when I.
When I believed in my heart that me and
Tom Cruise were friends.
When I got to talk to him for about an
hour and a half and we're having a deep
discussion and of course met him before
that because I did a reading with him
and we were having this great talk and I
was even like teasing them going,
what's it like to be the king?
I did just.
Do you have certain shows?
No,
no.
It was a good conversation with her,
but I remember thinking to myself,
if this guy's gay,
he's very cute.
He's got a little face and I thought to
myself,
this guy's gay and he really wanted to
be my friend and I can hang out with him
and I was drunk enough.
Do you think you can take your whole hog
and it's my self.
It's got a little face.
Hey,
don't talk about my Dick here.
I'm talking about my mouth,
Bro.
I don't need you to talk about the Dick
Sucking.
I didn't say that.
His face.
If it's a small face,
you're going to pick a guy to fuck.
You definitely want one that can blow
you.
Yes.
I need a small.
Got It.
I need a small head about,
not heads,
but if it's a big head than you can get
your whole Dick and his mother.
No,
no.
I like.
I like really shoehorn that bad boy.
Now you're gonna.
Have to snake.
Just got to unhinge your jaw here.
It's not going to be comfortable around
ratchet and hard surfaces.
Man.
You want more soft surfaces?
Shoe it in there.
I'll get some butterflies or sticking
stuff into their lips.
And what are they doing?
They're accentuating soft surface area.
Yeah.
We're trying to get you more excited
about them.
Put Your Dick in her mouth.
I'm also a fan of that and that's what
I'd make Tom too.
If we were dating.
I met fast by the way.
Women are,
they're shooting their lips up again.
It's getting more prevalent.
See it all the time.
I don't get it.
I don't like it.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
I'll get.
Apparently now they can do it where it's
not so hard,
you know?
Or before they were doing it and then
the lips would be hard and that kind of
freaked people out.
I have a problem with the hard lips,
five years I've kissed hard lips before
if kiss fake lips.
I don't like what's just a bizarre
compromise because the one of the
sexiest things about kissing is like the
feeling of someone's lips moving with
your lips and their tongue moving with
your tongue and then all of a sudden you
have this like third partner there is
implant and you feel it and you're
rubbing it around and each other's
mouths and it's like what is in your
lip?
But you know what lip and then there's
like you got an Oreo lip cream filling
in this lip.
There's some shit going on in there.
But they've said that some people
are driven by.
So if you and I look at a woman,
right?
We look at her lips big,
so I love big lips,
red lips,
soft lips.
You look at her breasts,
she looked and I think to myself what
that would feel like,
right?
The what?
I guess what triggers me is the idea of
what those lips would feel like to kiss
or grab and becomes this primal thing,
but they say some people are more drawn
driven by like the visual stimulus.
So some guys prefer fake tits.
In fact,
they even liked them to look fake.
They like big lips.
Some guys will tell their girls to get
big lips.
They'll tell their girls to get,
you know,
big fake tits because they'd rather that
even though they're hard,
they're willing to compromise the feel
for the visual and,
and so depending on what you're driven
by that is.
There's a book written about this,
and I can't remember the book,
but I'm in a very small portion of
people are driven by auditory stimulus.
So your voice might be enough to get a
girl going.
You could look like,
you know,
whatever.
Something's not attractive,
but your voice is what gets her going.
So it all depends on what triggers
people,
what they're overwhelming,
sort of what the connection is to their
senses.
You know,
the probably the biggest one,
the biggest difference from men and
women is the desire for successful
companion and men don't give a fuck if a
woman's successful.
No,
they don't at all.
I was going to ask you that.
What do you think it is?
Because it's not just about beauty.
Going back to that robot thing,
you know,
I've dated,
we've always had beautiful women in my
life.
You know,
I've,
but there's always one you,
you fall on who you're compatible with.
A lot of women,
you know,
I've,
I've loved many women in my life,
but there's,
there's something about some women that
gets you to shack up with them.
Well,
the same thing with friends too.
It's like what?
Why do you,
why did you and I become instant best
friends,
right?
Like right away,
like I met you when we're on a set of
mad TV and like
then,
like 20 minutes,
like make me stick together,
stick together.
Yeah.
We're going to be okay.
[inaudible] finally,
I found what I mean,
we've been best friends from that moment
on,
like literally we were close
immediately,
but there's other people that you meet
and you're like,
fuck right and get outta here and they
might be fine.
And then someone might say,
oh my God,
have you met Mike?
He's amazing.
And you're like,
yeah,
Mike's a good guy.
Yeah,
I'm bored,
but yeah,
you're bored.
Bored.
I don't want to do it.
What is that?
Was that,
is that just personalities who don't
resonate with drive?
Some people fucking crazy.
Your wife loves it,
you know,
it's like who you are versus who they
are.
Like sometimes it goes like this shoot
and the,
the,
the fingers of the hand fit into the
fingers,
the other hand and everything's great
chemical and other times it's just,
they're clashing teeth and you know,
you ever kissed somebody in clash teeth.
You know what in the fuck are we doing
here?
Nope.
Neither one of us know what the hell
we're doing.
Clinic.
It's just perfect.
Yes.
Some people,
the sex is like that too.
It's like it's rhythmic.
It moves,
it flows and other people.
It's just clunky and it's the same
person.
You're the same person and for whatever
reason it might not them.
It might be you.
It might be the two of you together.
You just fucking and that.
I think that that's part of the
mechanism that makes this weird world
work.
Human beings,
the way I view them are a gigantic super
organism working towards some sort of an
unknown technological goal.
I felt like if I had to do a one
sentence overview of the human race,
that's what I would say and I think that
somewhere along the line,
our individual personalities and our
individual hobbies and obsessions and
desires,
all of those,
although they appear to be coming from
us uniquely and us as an individual and
even though we relate to tribes who are
also into,
you know,
whatever Jujitsu or kettle bells or
ballet or whatever the fuck it is.
Ultimately all these pieces fit into
place as these portions of this super
organism that make things flow in a
forward direction and whether you're
obsessed with architecture or whether
you're obsessed with achieving peak
fitness or running a thousand miles in
an hour,
whatever the fuck it is,
all of those things are working together
collectively in the entire super
organism of the human race and they're
working towards some sort of a
technological goal because that's the
technological world and the world of
technological innovation.
It's slowly but surely integrating
itself into our lives.
If we looked at it objectively,
we'd be like,
Whoa,
this is like a life form that's asking
to be born from the husks of human
civilization like it's gonna go inside
of us and it's going to give birth like
some sort of aquatic worm that comes out
of a fucking grasshopper talks into
jumping into a pond.
I think it's interesting that human
beings are spending enough time creating
virtual experiences so that eventually,
if you look at the trajectory of this
and the technology under a play,
you're going to be able to have
experiences of what it's like to be
someone else.
Yeah,
for sure.
So if you can download it into their
brain or whatever,
we're already there already.
There's this thing called the empathy
project.
I think the same where you go to a room
and they bring the Syrian refugee crisis
to you.
They put you put on a virtual,
these virtual goggles and you're inside
the tent of a rush refugee family in a
refugee camp.
Kids are playing the mom and dad or
they're cooking food and you can see it.
You can hear it,
you can feel it,
and they're all around you.
It's three dimensional and it gives you
a sense of what programs is for programs
to museum.
It's a museum.
There you go.
God,
I love the collection of virtual reality
experiences to help us see the world
through the eyes of another.
This is a beautiful idea.
What an amazing idea.
Yeah,
so what happened on the back that up,
back up so I could read it because
there's so back it up.
Yeah,
but you could back up the video.
No,
you can't rewind it.
Oh,
it's.
it's the video on their website.
Oh,
okay.
And it isn't that amazing.
So now you can experience what it's like
to be someone else who's been through a
hard time and realize in many ways that
they're very human.
Why have all these emotional triggers
around Arabs and stuff?
Because I grew up in the Arab world and
they are.
They're very much people to me,
right?
The Middle East,
that this system,
this strange place with all those
fanatics that when you grow up there the
way I did,
you lived there for eight years of your
life.
You have a very different point of view
on the Middle East and the Arabs.
What I think of when I think of Arabs is
I see a smiling face and a welcoming
mat.
I see somebody who is making me tea and
bringing me into their house and given
me food.
I see a group of them who are laughing
their ass off and having a blast and I
see people hugging and holding hands.
That's just how I grew up.
So I have an emotional trigger when I
hear people stereotype Arabs in a
certain way.
Right.
It's just an interesting thing.
So I think that's because I had that
virtual experience and I love this idea
because as we are able to experience
what it's like to be someone else and
realize how similar they are to us,
despite all the cultural differences.
Hopefully it'll make for at least a
more.
I,
you know what the problem is all is,
is.
Yeah.
It'll make for a more understanding
world until I got to compete for fucking
water and my daughter's thirsty.
Now I'm going to have to off you will
see much seems like there's plenty of
water.
I think the biggest problem that we've
got right now is that we've been going
through a war with the Middle East for
13 years and when you go through a war
for 13 years,
what is the Ta,
you know,
like say if you do something like if
you're on heroin for six years,
how long does it take for that to the
effects of your body to bounce back from
being on heroin for six years because
it's not going to be a week,
right?
Is it going to be a year?
A couple of years is going to be half
the time I was going to be three years.
Whatever it is.
You've got to think of a war as being
something like some sort of horrible
trauma to an organism takes.
Generally it takes a generation.
At least it's like a scar that has to
heal over and it has to be worked on.
I mean you have many generations,
so they're gonna.
Remember grandpa getting blown up when
he was in a wedding party because they
thought that he was with talking to the
Jews about the genesis on the mall and
costs to the Armenians about the
genocide and you know,
in 1914 or 18 whenever it was.
Yeah,
they're still out in the street of
course.
Right.
What's the.
Dan Carlin talks about how there's such
fresh memories,
even if you say to a Chinese person that
you have a point of view on sort of the
benefits of Mongol expansion.
Even though that was how many years it
was.
12 slash 60 or whatever it was.
You'll get a lot of Chinese either.
You'll get a lot of people.
It's still somehow fresh trauma lasts
and is passed down through generation to
generation.
You know what I mean?
If you've ever been to Japan,
one of the things that people always
talk about is how the older Japanese
people do not like Americans and why
fucking day.
You know,
we dropped two nuclear bombs on their
little tiny ass country.
Yeah.
I think that it's super hard to erase
the memory of horrific events and the 13
years of war,
no matter whose side you're on,
that is a horrific event.
It's all in this one area,
so that's that.
I mean,
that's kind of take a long time before
we can look at Arabs,
the way you look at Arabs being there.
Of course,
and that's unfortunate man.
It's unfortunate because it's one of
those self perpetuating things like if
you're afraid of people,
if you think people are out to get you,
then they become out to get you.
You know,
like they,
they,
you realize that you're taking these big
giant steps to keep them away from you.
You're prejudice against them and
they're going to be upset that you're
prejudiced against them.
And then.
But I love Americans because Americans
always go out of their way.
Like all Americans go out of their way
to be like,
I don't care.
There's this idea that all the trump
supporters are these fanatics and they,
they're anti this net.
I guarantee.
I guarantee that the majority of people
in all the states that red states would
give any Syrian or Arabic guys,
Americans,
and I guarantee the creative would be,
hey,
they're human beings.
I'm willing to give them a chance if
they're good people,
they're good people.
This idea that they're terrorists eat
mother bugs and now I'm just niggling
guy with a gun.
I don't buy that.
I think definitely a lot of people,
there are a lot of people like that,
but on an individual basis,
I guarantee most people are intelligent
enough to go.
I'll take him as it comes.
I treat individuals the way they are.
I,
I think we are tribal.
I think we're.
Everybody has their own racial
prejudices and things like that,
but I think it's way more layered and
nuanced and a lot of people,
but for a lot of people,
people really fucking simple and their
ideology says that,
you know,
Christianity is the only way and this
ideology of the Muslims is dangerous.
The Prophet Mohammed was a dangerous
person.
These are dangerous people and we let
them over here.
We're taking a big chance America land
of the free home of the brave for you.
That may be the collective dialog.
I don't think that's the individual.
For example,
I think most of them,
if somebody was Arabic and they had an
opportunity to leave their alleviate
their suffering by bringing them into
their house and giving them a meal.
I think you watched so many Bruce Willis
movie,
I think.
I think the.
The most of them would do it.
I really do.
Well,
I think most of them,
if they knew the people for sure.
I think overcoming prejudices against
cultures or religions or anything or
very difficult to do because once those
things are set in stone,
it's like your body as a warning pattern
that it's looking for like up these
patterns repeating itself.
We've seen this before.
This is religious fundamentalism.
This is a people that are crazy.
They're going to blow themselves up and
to an extent you know that's not,
that's not misplaced.
So when I hear of a bomb going off or a
guy driving a truck and running over 80,
80 people in France,
my first,
my first guess,
and I'm always right,
is that he's probably a young Muslim
male that doesn't make me anti Muslim.
It doesn't make me anti Arab,
it just means I'm pretty good or not
even.
I don't have to be that good at pattern.
Yeah.
Well we
also have to really take into
consideration the sheer numbers of human
beings that we're dealing with on a
daily basis where you're getting the
news from getting the news from the
events that happened to 7 billion people
and that's just way too many for us to
make rational discussions about it.
Because rationally you should know about
what the fuck is happening in France.
You shouldn't know that some Muslim guy
drove a truck over all these people.
You're not there.
Right?
And there's some,
you know how many other Muslim men
didn't run over somebody with a truck
that day.
So that's where it gets weird.
Yeah,
because you don't even take those people
into consideration when you're talking
about Muslim males.
You're only talking about those one
males.
It's like gun owners,
like people have this idea of gun owners
and gun owners are a bunch of fucking
paranoid nuts with canned food in their
basement.
They're buying gold from Alex Jones.
No,
no,
no.
The occasionally one of those guys
shoots up a school occasionally,
but you know how many people own guns?
There's more guns in this country than
there are fucking people.
Yeah,
so we've really had like this crazy gun
problem.
Things would be going off way more than
they do.
It's remarkably safe considering the
amount of fucking firearms are available
to markably.
Incredibly.
Yeah.
Like almost every day of your life.
You go through town and you don't hear a
single gunshot,
but that's also going back to what I was
saying about you,
you know when,
when somebody owns a gun,
they're like,
rose McGowan says,
somebody says smile,
and she immediately says,
I'm not.
I'm putting words in your mouth,
but this is essentially what we said in
the interview,
that that guy is being in one way or
another sexist or being in one way or
another somewhat oppressive and
suppressive.
I'm sure she feels that what I'm saying
is that for,
for that guy,
he may just be clumsily trying to say hi
to some of the most beautiful creature
he's ever seen in his life because at
the same way with gun owners,
gun owners,
a lot of time,
hold on,
let me stop you there because couldn't
it be both things?
It could be both.
Sent it to him.
It could be this one thing to her like,
look,
if you really,
really into raping girls and it makes
you feel awesome and you don't want them
to feel like it's rape,
but it is 100 percent that they're
always there.
They're equating those two,
but I'm just saying that there could be
two different things going on.
His intention and the actual results.
One hundred percent.
I'm just saying when you draw these
blanket statements like so when men
owned guns,
right?
If you hear the dialogue on the left,
a lot of times it's like,
well,
you know,
these gun nuts.
Are these gun owners who are into all
this other stuff,
this macho stuff,
or are a lot of men owned guns?
A lot of men's can sound crazy.
Lot of men on guns like me because it's
the most effective way to protect my
family in case somebody comes in my
house in the middle of the night.
That's actually something I think about
a something.
I'm ready for it.
Something I prepare for the past 20
years.
A lot of men do that.
I'm crazy.
I'm just saying at the end of the day,
Brian only practices,
escape routes.
Got Paths for ambushes,
pinch points in his house.
I like pinch,
pinch,
pinch point is when you know people have
to travel through a corridor.
That's great.
Yeah.
So for like 300 words,
know.
Let me move it to
300.
The Persian side to come to you.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's a pinch and I need some hot gates
point set up a tree stand.
If you're hunting deer,
go to the pinch point.
If they have to make their way out into
the field,
I feel best go through the woods.
I feel my house,
my next house is going to be just a
fucking series of pinch points.
Oh,
where are you going to move to?
Somewhere where there a lot of pinch
points.
Are you going to stay in California
forever?
Probably.
I know.
Let me say it.
Let me put it this way.
I want to.
I want to just stand up forever.
Forever.
I'm never gonna stop going.
Wow.
I remember when you weren't doing it at
all.
Well,
I do it all the time and I never stopped
doing it.
My favorite did stop once.
I don't remember.
I don't know what you're talking about.
That's the only time that was a
different guy.
As a guy who dated my sister,
I was the guy who might be bugged with
her boyfriend broke up with bro.
We don't.
We do that though.
There's something about standups when
you find out that somebody quits stand
up,
you're like,
oh,
what happened?
Right.
What kind of life do you have?
No,
I just thought of that.
Fuck.
That's funny you say that.
What kind of life do you have now?
Just thought of somebody that I was
like,
what happened to that guy who was doing
a lot of stand up and you stopped.
I know man,
like you and I had a great fucking time.
Listen,
I had to come up.
Go down there.
It's sold out.
Killer show was so much fun.
What a blast.
That powerful Sam Tripoli specific,
by the way,
a monster.
Nobody knows her load.
He is.
How good is he?
He's gonna kill you.
He'll kill.
I brought him with me on the road once
in Edmonton at that place on fire
because he was getting ready for his cd
that he taped in Edmonton.
He hit you taped a CD at that club
there.
What's the club in Edmonton?
He's called me a comic strip.
Yeah,
that's blank Bronson Club.
We did,
um,
the casino up there that they always in
Edmonton where they always have fights
and I'm fucking.
What's the name I know they were
creating awesome place.
And two,
he lit it on fire.
Lit that place on fire.
Beast.
I call him the monster.
He can.
He can destroy tie on last night.
Yes she did.
I went to Afghanistan with that guy,
got his done.
Whoa.
Me,
him and Doug Davidoff and Steve Byrne
and he gay stuff happened.
Uh,
I'm not going to go into that.
may have met some soldiers.
I was there.
I was there traveling concubine in there
and they showed.
They showed me with a pinch point is,
whoa.
Yeah.
This is a pinch point right here on
appeal.
This piece right here.
Same Guy,
same guy.
Took me a school onto Haitian.
Um,
yeah,
it was pretty interesting.
But uh,
but Sam would get up and he would open
for us.
We'd go out there and just get a mic in
a little box and it's like,
that's an awkward with all these
soldiers sitting around in a war zone.
That dude lit it up every fucking time.
But one of the things about Sam is he,
like a lot of comics are comics has done
that room when there was zero crowd
control and he would get a lot of late
spots.
So you learned that combat comedy style
combat company.
He's like probably be more confident and
comfortable when shit goes crazy when
people start at him like,
Oh,
I've been
here before.
Here we go.
I know you ain't been here,
but I've been here.
Yeah,
let's roll buddy.
Yes.
My favorite was Savvis.
He's always changing his face.
His look,
he's got a goatee,
got a mustache,
got a full beard,
got no peer,
and I'm like shaved up because switched
up.
Sometimes you gotta switch it up,
like to switch it up sometimes.
Then he grabs my body and he goes,
how the fuck do you do it?
How do you do it?
You got the best body in comedy.
I go,
Joe Rogan,
best body of comedy and then I walk
away.
I love him.
He loves you.
I got to get him on the podcast is a
good dude.
The fighter and the kid.
Not,
not,
not the Brian Counseling.
We call it mixed mental arts now.
That's what you call them and I think
it's better mixed metal arts because
hunter was like,
yeah,
because hunt mixed mental arts is better
and we've been having these great
conversations and hunter was like,
let's stop being so myopic.
Let's just get all the ideas under one
umbrella.
Let's make ideas accessible to get to
pull the ambitious project,
but he's like,
I want to make sure everybody knows that
there's no such thing as being smart.
We can all know these ideas and have a
constructive conversation.
Well,
he's got a great attitude about it and
that really is the approach to that.
It's not about smart.
It's about information.
Like I've had conversations with people
about something and I'll explain
something to them and they go,
God,
I feel so stupid.
Like you're not stupid.
Like I'm not smart.
I just know this and the reason why I
know this is because somebody figured it
out and I bothered reading it.
That's it.
But we like hold that over people's
heads with like such extreme arrogance
because so many people want to cling to
almost anything as like a sign of
superiority.
Whether it's information that they have,
accomplishments that they've done,
the money that they have in the bank,
whatever the fuck it is.
Like they always constantly want to have
this thing that separates them from you.
Right.
You know,
and that's one thing that people love to
do with inflammation will,
if you had known if you read this then
you would know that Kaba you cut the
shit and just tell me that,
tell me and I'll have a car.
But it was also this thing that we all
do and that you and I've worked very
hard to stop doing over the last decade
or so,
which is to try to win conversations.
Yes.
Because it's a,
it's a fucking horrible impediment to
learning anything like that.
The best way to have a conversation is
mean challenge ideas for sure.
But just talk.
Yeah,
just talk.
Like if someone's telling you something
and you have a question,
don't look at it like you're attacking
it.
Look at it like what is this we're
discussing?
What is this actual thing like,
you know,
that weird thing that people do in these
shut.
They shut down and you know that they're
not really discussing what you're
saying.
They're just trying to find a way where
they could win the conversation.
Yeah.
Because their,
their point of view makes them feel a
certain way.
Yes.
And if you start to break down those
walls,
they're afraid you're going to take away
that feeling of security or whatever
that feeling is confidence in being
consistently,
right?
That's right.
That's a big one.
Yes.
So when someone's not right about
something,
like I have a good friend who's a animal
rights activist guide,
Vegan Guy,
and he was saying we were talking about
the precursors for hormone development
and whether or not saturated fat and
cholesterol are
the essential precursors to hormone
development.
Well,
it's pretty much established fact
scientific fact.
So in the.
He didn't think it was because he was
reading a lot of this ideological dogma
on it,
you know,
plant based dogma.
So I started sending them all this stuff
and then he's like,
okay,
I got it all right now as to.
So Ken,
now we can have a discussion about it.
We'll look at all this,
look at all these studies,
look at all these things like we're not
saying you should go out and be an
animal eater,
know what I'm saying that,
but look at the evidence,
that data,
look at what it actually is,
right,
and look what is the actual problem with
trying to study.
This is the actual problem with not
getting enough b12.
getting enough of this vitamin that
data,
saturated fat,
cholesterol,
all these fucking things that we were
told as kids are bad for you,
which is a huge problem because most
people don't learn anything about
nutrition past what they learn in
school.
I mean that's pretty much it.
Well,
one of the biggest things for me is just
having been around hunter as much as I
have and we always talk about how,
and I've had to confront so much of
this.
My own in my own way is I have a fast
thinking brain.
We all do,
right?
That fast thinking brand that jumps out,
that triggers that things.
Have you started talking about
liberalism?
If you start talking about big
government,
if you start talking about communism,
Marxism,
I get,
I'll get what happens is I'll get ready
to defend my free market.
America,
Fox News.
You have a show on Fox News.
I'm defending my dad.
That's what I'm doing.
I have an emotional attachment to that
and so I'll stop listening to you about
bout five seconds in and I've already
got my guns.
I'm already loaded my guns as you're
talking.
I'm going.
Hold on.
Let me get my gun so much.
Yeah,
yeah,
I hear you.
And now I can't wait to blast away at
your.
Your collective ideology.
Right?
And then I'll drop books like fix this
road to serfdom and all the things I've
read and all they want to do is win.
And so I've had to and we always talk
about this,
like hunter,
I'll send me articles that'll get me
enraged,
and I'll freak out and I'll write this
thing and he'll get me.
He'll go,
feel better.
Brian.
Now if you want to tranquilize the big
fast thinking elephant that you've been
riding and let's get some slow thinking
evolves and take a look at what,
how your feelings are driving there
thinking it's very.
It's a very fun exercise because as you
get older,
what happens is you're able to sit back
and somebody says something and you're
able to go,
instead of me loading my guns,
let me listen a little bit hard.
Let me see if I can get.
Take something from that.
Maybe there is a good argument.
Maybe there it may not be at a Marxist,
but maybe there is some value to
regulation.
Maybe there is some value to the FDA or
you know,
whatever it might be.
I've been reading.
So you,
you have free market sort of prejudices
in that regard where you lean towards
deregulation,
lean towards a freer market because more
money gets made.
Businesses does better.
Lean toward freedom of choice.
So I liked idea but,
but,
but environmental regulations where I
draw the line too,
that's like me.
That's a classic example of the fishing
game and wildlife.
What is it?
The wildlife,
the fish and game department of fish and
game.
Excellent job.
Yeah.
I don't care what anybody says.
You and I know and you know even more
than the states as well.
They all deserve recognition because
they.
They've brought animals back from the
brink of extinction to gigantic
populations to get drunk and they shoot
the shit out of everything that moves.
That's.
Well.
There was actually market farming.
Market farming is with didn't most of
the animals in this country.
After the war,
one of the things that happened was
there was a lot of soldiers after the
civil war that needed jobs and one of
the jobs that was available was market
farming.
What does that mean?
That means they didn't have
refrigerators back then,
buddy.
So if you wanted meat,
you had to go out and get it.
And so one of the things they would do
is they would hire these young men to
take their rifles and go out and shoot
every fucking buffalo that moved.
They would shoot buffalo just for their
tongues.
They would cut out the tongues of the
buffaloes.
They would shoot other ones just for
their pelts.
They would shoot.
They shot down everything in sight,
down to antelope.
It was harder to shoot antelope and kill
them off because they're designed from
the fucking to have things like cheetahs
chasing a smaller.
They still keep it.
Well,
they're faster than anything that can
catch them because they evolved during a
time where cheat as lived in North
America,
big cats lived in North America that
were bigger than lions and African
lines.
So when you're thinking about these
times and these people that wiped out
all the animals in this country,
there was a host of factors,
a bunch of different pressures on these
animals,
but a lot of it was market hunting.
Yeah,
and so when hunters came along,
like in the beginning of the 20th
century,
there was very few deer and defined like
a big deer with like a giant rack.
Super rare elk had been.
They'd been extra painted from a
gigantic segment of the population or
gigantic sub segment of the country,
and so they've slowly repopulated in
these groups.
Like the Rocky Mountain Elk Federation,
they've transplanted elk down to dearest
everywhere else.
Yeah.
Sell planning philosophy because they
corn and a lot of the agricultural crops
that were planted.
That is true and that's also why white
tail deer have done so much better than
mule deer.
Mule deer kind of,
you know,
in a much healthier position.
There's still have healthy populations
and they still hunt them and you find
them everywhere.
But mule deer,
they don't live off crops like white
tail deer is like our friend Doug
Durham's farm.
Doug has this awesome place in
Wisconsin.
Shout out to Doug.
Powerful doctor.
He has essentially they're farm animals,
but they're not.
They're wild.
They're these giant as wild deer,
but they openly go around his farm or
farms in the area is different every
year,
but some of the best meals I've ever had
by the way.
Incredible.
Like you're.
You're definitely getting like they're
eating that fucking monsanto corn.
Did you bring me any elk fucking for
real or fake game me.
Don't let me leave without a game.
We'd hunt more and that's the other
thing.
See you them to get balls deep,
like I'm tired of all the fucking talk
about this.
And you went hunting with me once and
then you motherfuckers,
but you never got crazy with it.
I got crazy with it.
I'm really missing hunting.
I said to my wife yesterday,
go and um,
but I miss the hangout.
You don't care.
We have a great time.
I started thinking I did something
wrong.
Well,
how much fun did we have?
Did we not?
All twice and had a great time.
Still laughed.
We had a fucking wonderful time.
Struck out the last time.
Went with Rinella.
Why don't we go to,
when are we going hunting?
You're hiking with him because he likes
to suffer and I'll hike with.
No,
no,
no.
You've got to come with us.
We gotta.
We gotta figure out a spot where we
could go.
Well,
we have a reasonable chance of success
because you always want the option,
the possibility rather than failing.
It really do like a.
You don't want to go hunting.
You don't want to shoot fish in a
barrel,
you know you want to go.
I like looking in what he does.
It is the best way.
Honestly,
I've hunted a bunch of different ways.
The most satisfying way in the way that
feels the best to me is public land.
You know,
because you get a tag,
you know,
you get a over the counter tag,
you're going public land,
you hunted animal,
you kill,
you eat it.
Everybody sits down over the fire.
And so one of the best moments in life.
Yes.
Yeah.
Rainelle is a master,
you know,
he really has a lot of the aspects of
life worked out in,
you know,
in like as far as like being a sportsman
in the 21st century and being a
spokesperson for it because he's so well
read and he's so smart and he's so
articulate and reasoned.
Like when he makes discussions and
debates with people about it,
his,
his approach is so intelligent.
It's very rare that you find someone in
that world that's so good at expressing
themselves.
Yeah,
he's amazing.
He's so knowledgeable.
He's always got something to surprise.
You always got something to say,
but we got to go.
We should go.
I want to maybe go elk hunting or
something.
I know you bought me a bow.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And you won't have,
which we're going to set you up with a
new one,
like the one I gave you.
You got it a year and a half ago.
Care.
What's wrong with that?
With that?
They have new ones they're getting into
and I'm thinking the one you gave.
I'm not trading my unused.
Both my brand new.
Well you have graphite dust on it still,
but carbon carbon spider.
It's a really good bow.
Yeah.
Well believe me.
I'll be saying it's a carbon spider.
Yes.
Is it carbon spider?
It's called the carbon spider.
Yes.
I was going to say it was made of carbon
spider and they y d,
e R.
I don't know why they use the word
spider for like Porsche boxster.
Spyder,
spy,
d,
e R.
I don't know why.
So it's for like certain cars that are
convertibles,
but it's also for that bow.
Maybe it's a trademark thing and maybe
the spider loving,
but it's a really good bow.
The hoyts of the best.
There's like,
whoa.
There's like three or four really good
bowman manufacturers.
It's generally,
there are six year listeners like it
gets into fucking generally a thought of
that.
It's white and matthews are the top bows
and the.
That's the only fucking bizarre shit
elite.
And then there's Bowtech,
which is also really up there too,
and it's really depends on who you ask.
I'm a white guy.
You got a whole.
Yeah,
I'm awake.
I didn't get any better.
There's nothing better than a white.
It's matthews.
The question is like,
if you talk to guys like John Dudley,
he'll,
he'll say that hoists are better.
He said like that in his opinion.
And he knows way more than me.
He thinks that hoist to the best pose in
the world.
So I just listened to him and Cameron
Hanes has the same thing,
so you guys would know.
Nobody knows more about no bow hunting
and bowhunting.
Now,
uh,
you know,
I'm in a scope from,
from animals,
so I will shoot,
like if I need meat and I'm running low
on me,
I'll hunt an animal with a rifle.
Okay.
But what I'm really into,
man,
is archery.
I love archery even if I never bow
hunted again and even if I just hunted
with a rifle because it was too hard to
bowhunt,
which it's not,
and I will bow hunt again for sure,
but archery is,
to me it's a.
it's like a meditation.
It's archery's a martial art in a lot of
ways,
but it's a stillness martial art.
It's a martial art where you're
perfecting one move.
This one move of having your arm out in
front of you.
Your hand is like in a halt position,
like that's where it is,
and then the Bho doesn't pass over the
lifeline you wanted on this side of the
lifeline so it never goes deep in your
grip so you're not torquing your wrist,
so it's basically just balanced up
against your hand and then you're
pulling back and you're locking in your
anchor point and you're looking through
your peep site and all you're
concentrating on is pulling back your
scapula and releasing that era without
moving at all.
Now what about,
what about emotion do.
How bent is your straight line?
Straight?
What about,
but last time,
I do think that ended a little bit.
Last time I did that,
the [inaudible] your stances.
I hit my fucking hand and I.
Yeah,
because you're all out hurt so badly.
You're supposed to be like,
this is right,
but I've hit my forearm before it hurts
a little bit.
Yeah,
but just don't.
You shouldn't ever hit your forum.
If you're,
if you're shooting correctly,
you'll be in a position where the big
toe of your foot lines up with the ball
of your rear foot,
so your front foot,
big toe and your rear foot ball.
And that gives you a slightly open
stance.
Very slightly martial arts.
They love this stuff.
I love.
I love technique like that will you to
learn from Dudley because John Dudley
from.
He's got a podcast that if you want a
super geek out about archery,
it's a podcast called knock on and the
knock on podcast is John's podcast where
he discusses like intricate details
about cam timing and Arrow weights and,
and,
uh,
front of center,
how much,
uh,
how much kinetic energy each arrow has
based on what percentage of weight is in
the front of the Arrow.
It's like,
what I love about that is when you
master something like Dudley in
a way,
you learn everything in a way.
You're learning so much about life.
Maybe everything that's relevant about
life in some ways.
I know you're going to get Orthodox and
you're thinking your brain patterns will
be a certain way.
But like when you start talking that way
and he's thinking about like grade and,
and wait and aerodynamics and like,
yeah,
great discipline.
What archery really is,
is a rabbit hole and you know,
you could,
some people go down that rabbit hole and
they go fuck this rabbit hole.
And they get like an old school recurve
bow and just learn instinctive shooting
and they just get into just releasing
the Arrow on their own and knowing.
It's almost like you throw a rock if you
throw a rock,
you know your arm feels like you kind of
know where that rocks can it go.
And then you get pretty accurate about
throwing rocks.
But if you want to get really accurate,
you gotta throw rocks every day.
And that's the same thing with recurve
bows.
If you have the exact same weight arrow.
So if you have a stack of these arrows
and you shoot,
you know that if you bend it this way
and you pull it back to here,
it goes that far.
Okay.
I'll say,
well if the animals here,
then I gotta aim here and you just
develop this Eliel in your own mind or
where the Arrow's going to go.
But it's not that accurate.
It's like if you have an animal with a
recurve,
like I've watched hunting shows where
people hunt animals with recurves
wounding of animals.
There's a lot of sketchy shots.
Whereas like if you watch,
like John Dudley puts out some videos of
some of the hunters on,
they're all getting shot through the
heart.
I'm like 99 percent of the animals,
like they don't even know what happened.
And then there.
It's interesting though,
like I was thinking about this because
I've been obsessing over boxing,
you know,
lately.
And I like the reason I like to spar as
I don't get.
I'm not knocking my head off and stuff
and like Brendan's always like don't
spar and stuff.
But for me what I really love is the
same thing I loved about taekwondo,
which is that with boxing it seems so
impossible when you first started and
then like two years,
two and a half years later,
if you're actually sparring and moving
around with people,
you'll start developing patterns.
If you have a good teacher and you'll
start to learn how to get somebody to
think one thing,
right?
So you jab and the jab low,
then you fake joe and you and maybe fly
into a hook or whatever and you learn to
protect you and you can start developing
your own sort of similar patterns that
aren't.
It's a different discipline than
archery.
Archery seems so kinetic and detailed,
right?
Boxing is more kinetic,
it's more.
Um,
but it was more options box.
Yeah.
There's a lot of strategy.
There's a lot of split second timing.
There's a lot of,
uh,
getting your opponent to.
You're fooling him.
Really.
You're getting to think you're doing one
thing and then capitalizing on,
on,
on sort of a.
you're saying,
I thought I was doing this and I'm doing
this.
You know,
there's a different kind of thing.
But what I,
what I love about all of it is almost
like,
it's not even so much about the doing of
it,
of itself.
It's always awesome.
But I think what I really get off on
sometimes is the discovery is the PR is
the learning maybe how to control
something that seems so out of control
and,
and sort of the discovery,
the continual discovery of new things
and maybe what it does to my brain.
Like maybe,
maybe that's what I like,
like the,
the mindset it puts me in and the
understanding it gives me and maybe even
the fact that it takes away the,
some of the mystery I was living under,
which I felt was a little learning one
new thing.
Now that one new thing is unearthed.
No,
understand that a little bit better.
You've got a little bit more data.
Yeah.
And then now I'm not as intimidated by
anything.
Like,
I mean somebody who is quote unquote,
really smart and good at one thing,
whether it's a surgeon or a brain
surgeon or a scientist or a really good
fighter.
Well a really good fighter.
I've talked to Joe Schilling about this
and to Dallas,
Ronnie about this,
you know,
I was talking about patterns I'd come up
with is I was talking about this pattern
I had and he goes,
yeah.
And she was showing said,
so we'd have.
So the differences,
I probably have 30 of those patterns
that I,
that I have deepened my memory.
It's like Roberta Duran,
I can't remember who was fighting him,
but he came back and he said the fucking
guy can read my mind and as I think it
was,
his trainer said,
he's not reading your mind.
What he's doing is that he knows those
patterns so well and he sees you about
the set him up and he's,
and he's beating you to it,
you know,
and when I watched a Henner gracie tie
up,
tie up the likes of Brendan Schaub and
Leo Machida and all kinds of guys in
there.
And I watched him just do whatever you
wanted.
Starting to his back.
And I was like,
I was like,
dude,
you're,
you're anticipating their movements.
You are already see what their patterns
are because you're ahead of them.
And it takes a little bit.
You're not going to be as reverential.
You're going to be.
You're going to love the fact that life
is that way,
that the universe can be that way,
that if you practice something enough
and you get good enough at something,
it can seem like what you do is magic
almost right,
but it's not.
It's just that you have learned how to
chunk large portions of information and
you will learn how to be ahead of
somebody and more importantly,
when you play somebody at the same game,
you're going to see the tendencies,
they're going to make tendencies and
you're gonna beat them to.
Those tendencies can be able to head
them off.
Why?
Because you've been there a thousand
times because you went through the same
thing and the difference between your
practicing beginner mind and your
mastery mind in that context is vastly
different.
And I can always tell somebody who's
mastered something versus somebody who's
never taken the time to really get good
at something.
I can always tell the difference and I
prefer to be around.
Not always.
Not always,
because I got some real more on friends
that are so much fun,
but I typically tend to find more
intimacy in conversation with people
that have least continue to endeavor
down the road to mastery.
Well,
there's very few people that can talk to
them,
you know,
if you're,
if you're to talk to a real master about
something,
you know,
pull someone aside and talk to them
about their craft,
about achieving incredibly high level at
a very difficult discipline.
Like a master chess player for instance.
How many people did they have to talk to
see if Gary Kasparov is,
uh,
at a.
and somebody wants to have a
conversation with him about food stamps
or fucking Hollywood gossip,
Hollywood gossip,
right?
Whatever happened to Taylor swift and
like,
that kind of shit.
He says,
hang inaccurate oculus.
Like,
I can't believe what John did like.
So he was.
So I was walking down and then he said I
was going to grab this package.
And he added or someone's next to him
and it's Sam Harris and Sam Harris and
Gary Kasparov have this deep,
intense conversation that,
that fills a void inside of their souls,
fills them up.
Right.
And it's really hard to find someone
that can play ping pong with you,
like intellectually at that level.
Well,
because it maybe it goes back to the
same,
same thing we were talking about.
They're about to have a real discussion
and they're not as attached to their
prejudices,
right?
Because they tend to be like Sam Harris
is like,
if you listened to Sam Harris talk about
trump.
His critique is so fair.
It's so.
It's so interesting.
Like he's got these great metaphors and
stuff,
but it's not driven by dogma.
It's not driven by my team is right near
team is wrong.
He's,
he's able to be more objective.
He's more humble.
Like Wayne McCullough,
who's might my trainer,
my boxing trainer,
like,
you know,
a former world champion he's been
through.
When you're a world champion like that,
he's the most humble motherfucker on the
planet.
He's,
he'll hold mitts for everybody.
Clap your hands.
He's the greatest guy in the world and
he doesn't get the respect.
Nobody knows who the,
how,
what he accomplished as a boxer.
It drives me fucking crazy,
but that doesn't matter.
That fucking guy.
He'll give you every really level headed
God.
Amazing.
Yeah.
Like one of my favorite people on the
planet.
I love that mother family was amazing
boxer and his day,
God,
and a great teacher in a very
lightweight guy.
So it was lightweight guys.
The ones that have the real technical
skill and footwork and movement.
Yes.
So he teaches you boxing?
Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
He's my.
He's my guy.
Yeah,
man.
He.
Steven moves around with me.
I'll put on gloves and you know,
just.
It's funny how he may be small like
that,
but good luck trying to hit him.
Yeah.
Well good luck.
When he,
when he catches you in the body and you
make your 15 mistakes.
I love it though.
It's so humbling.
Do you think you'll ever get to Jujitsu
again?
I am dying to.
It seems to me like that one you could
kind of.
You could actually do it in a way where
you're not going to get hurt.
That's the big difference between
striking and wrestling and grappling.
I love grappling.
It's what I started with and I miss it
and I love it.
I liked the way it makes my body feel
and everything else and grappling like
Jujitsu,
you can get really good and you can roll
with top level guys when you box and if
you want to get good,
you got to spar and every time I spar
with,
you know,
I'm not sparring tough guys and I'm
sparring pros like my buddy Brandon
Adams who can do whatever he wants to
me.
He just moving around with me and
touched me.
It's great.
I learned you're still getting hit.
It's still going to get hit.
You can still gonna take a couple shots
and if you fight somebody who's like
your level,
somebody's going to get,
that's when you actually get hurt,
right?
Because you know I'm not,
I don't want to lose.
You don't want to lose.
Even though I'm 50 and I'm an idiot for
doing this,
I'm still going to.
I still try to hold onto my fucking,
you know,
Blah Blah.
We'll just move around and tell you,
catch me and then I'm going to try to
catch it stings and your.
I would prefer not to do it.
It's nerve wracking.
You know who loves it?
Lucy Kay.
He likes to box.
Yup.
No Shit.
Giant boxing fan too.
So that all the big.
Does he spar Louis?
Just wow.
Yeah.
He and I had a pretty deep conversation
about boxing,
like he's a fucking real boxing fan when
we were talking about guys like terrence
Crawford or like,
oh look at you.
Yeah,
he loves it.
I just watched Tommy hearns fight with
Hagler fight with sugar ray.
Holy Shit.
And hearns fight with Doran.
I do.
That's my thing.
I go,
I watch,
say think you can dance the best of so
he can.
Thinking that's the voice.
I cry my private,
my little private garden and then I
watch old boxing bouts and it's my
favorite thing and I watched interviews
with them now interviews with Tommy
hearns and that Jabba his.
Oh,
it was amazing.
Oh my God.
Do you ever see his fight with Roberto
Duran?
Sure did.
He was one of the first guys to
flatline.
A guy like Roberto Duran.
Just leave are laid out the first round.
Second round.
I think it was the second.
Yeah,
second round.
It's hard to remember,
but it was around two.
He hit him like a pistol compliant.
Six one.
One 45.
This is ridiculous.
And he was wide,
so wide torque behind the punches.
I liked Roger Mayweather fight,
uh,
in his prime black Mamba Dude.
And he had legs that were about as
skinny as toothpick.
Well,
they look like nine x cables.
They're just like these tiny.
I've never seen anything like it.
Good luck finding him too.
Yeah,
there's hearns flat over bird around.
Look at that picture.
He was a giant 45,
but yeah,
he was.
I think in this time though,
he was 54.
I think you went up to 54.
That was a because Roberto Duran had
beaten Davey Moore and I think that was
at 54.
Was it at 60?
Because Roberto follow all the way up to
Hagler.
He's my favorite.
Roberto Duran was my favorite fighter
jet.
I just.
His attitude like the human pit bull,
the stair,
how much he loves fire.
Hearns is than him.
Good Lord.
Different,
different.
Literally a different looking human
beings.
Yeah.
Look at that picture of him jabbing them
right there.
David and Goliath right there.
Fucking.
He's a large fellow.
Tommy hearns and Duran.
Loved to fight.
He.
He needed to stay the fuck away from
microphones to.
Yeah.
Perhaps that whole talking things over.
Then I watched some hagler.
I watched some marvelous Marvin Hagler.
Oh,
he was amazing.
Marvelous.
Margaret.
I,
I still to this day maintain that.
Gross should have won that fight with
sugar ray Leonard started,
I think,
enough to win.
He's just touching them.
I agree.
One hundred percent.
How do you think the big questions are?
People ask these but Connecticut,
Lufkin with Hagler.
Um,
you know,
these kinds of.
We'll never know.
We'll never get the real question is
what's Gennady Golovkin going to do it
with Canelo Alvarez.
Floyd mayweather things.
Canelo Alvarez.
Gonna Knock Lufkin out.
I think Lufkin is bigger,
taller,
longer.
He hits bit as hard.
Um,
and I think,
I think it's a little much for Canelo.
I'm interested.
I want to see what Gennady and Andre
Ward would have.
What would the thing is,
did you see the fight with Kell Brooks?
Kell Brooks had some serious moments.
He did.
He made the human.
But the problem was,
from what I understand,
you also had a bad flu.
Yes.
Oh really?
He had a bad flu.
Will that change?
And then can I proceeded to break it?
Kells,
uh,
I think orbital socket and beat him up
eventually.
But the thing is as fucking hell of a
hell of a fighter.
Yeah.
But the thing is,
Kell Brooks is not Canelo Canelo's a
murderous one punch knockout artists.
You know,
it's,
it's a totally different experience.
Like Canelo can flat line people and he
does it.
He does it with bombs.
So the question is whether or not he'll
ever be able to get one of those bombs
off.
Well,
if you watch them with Amir Khan,
he would keep,
he'd fake loan,
He Jab,
Jab,
logo,
and it didn't work like eight times.
And then finally Chad Lowe,
boom.
And just came to the top and just knock
them out that that's.
I think that's one of his Mane Gotu
shots.
I don't know.
Again,
that is a different animal.
Totally different animal,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean he has a way better chin,
but he also.
He also makes you pay for things.
You throw his,
his counters when you get hit,
you know,
my friends are heavyweight at box and
burn.
I'm David.
And he used to spar with him and
wherever he'd wear a body suit when he's
the.
With Godaddy for a small box and burn.
Change your name change.
It's doing very well.
No,
no,
no.
It's boxing gym.
I mean,
seriously.
It's like you have boxing mixed with
like Jane Fonda workouts.
Do you feel the burn guy?
Real fighters and they're real actors,
get some serious actors to get real
actress.
Oh yeah.
Oh my goodness.
Is that why you're there?
Love works with Wayne McCullough.
I'm burning.
Hey,
that's my boy's gym.
It's a great challenge in my calves are
burning on this.
Don't do that.
That's not how we do it though.
What are you doing?
Skipping rope.
I've never seen a that way.
Your nipples.
I can see your nipples.
See your shirt and I'm getting a little.
It's an amazing gym.
It's an amazing gym so that when you go
like this,
I can lift weights and have a hard time
breathing.
Yeah,
that's way to have a hard time.
Every lifts weights and hyperventilate.
If you had a gym called lift weights and
hyperventilate.
Really funny.
Everybody be like,
what the fuck kind of name for a gym is
this boxing burn,
burning it rit band at fucking roof off
this bitch.
Well,
you're not gonna.
You're not going to be able to make
money in a gym if you just have box and
good luck opening a gym.
We just teach you how to fight.
You get six people to show out that we
liked.
We liked it.
We teach the class.
It is a good place for dudes who like
the box and then smoke some weed and
chill out afterwards.
Box and burn workout.
And do you ever get high before you work
out?
Never.
Never have.
That seems odd.
I was in boxing Ireland time and I was
dead lifting a 1:45
for reps though for Reps.
and hold it over your head or a.
well,
again,
I was looking at skinny,
my,
my third,
uh,
my uh,
arm was good to get some iron man and
kettlebells Mulan those bits.
Well I've been,
I've been taking a weight lifting class
which we can get into.
I liked that very much.
So we talk about that on it,
uh,
ironman thing.
But um,
I'm,
I'm deadlifting and Tim Teebo and
Brendan Schaub Walk in behind me.
Oh boy.
And I got embarrassed and I put it down.
Don't work out when I'm talking.
I sort of sweating.
I sweat a lot.
I drink a lot of water and very hydrated
for the whole,
like what they're saying,
I'm just going to start lifting.
It's okay because I don't know because
I'm just talking about dead lifting in
front of those guys at 1:45.
That's impressive.
Have you tried to Max out?
No.
No,
I don't Max out,
man.
What do you think?
If you really had to,
what do you think you could bench?
Uh,
I used to do what's three plates?
Three.
Oh,
five.
Three slash five slash three slash 15
was 2:25
and 95?
Yeah,
I could do three.
Oh,
five for three or four?
Three 52 plates?
Yeah.
Oh,
is that what it is?
Okay.
That's a lot of weight.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I can do that.
Have you ever tried to dead lift Max?
Um,
no,
never did left at Max,
but I would work out with 4:50.
So what does that work out you deadlift
for 50?
Yeah,
I did look for 50.
You work out with 450 pounds.
Four hundred 50 pounds a fuck load of
weight.
What do you mean?
It's not that much weight on a crossbar,
but it's a,
it's on a straight bar.
What kind of bar?
Those ones?
Just stand inside those hexagon bars and
grabbed the side.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a fuck load of weight.
What are you talking about?
Strong as fuck,
Bro.
Yeah.
That's been dead deadlifting for a long
time.
You know,
I started out dead lifting to 25 and
then I went up to three plates and now I
four plates a little bit more.
You know,
it's total nine plates plus the bars.
Well he's twenty five cents.
That's a fuck little weight.
Yeah,
but only do it for like two or three
reps.
what I want,
what I believe is that when you get to a
certain proficiency at lifting right
then and only then should you lift
heavy,
right?
You've,
you've built up like a good solid base.
Then only then should you live to heavy.
And I follow like the Tat Salini
Protocol where like say if I can do 10
reps or something,
I never do 10,
I do five.
So like if I get to like if I'm doing
something heavy,
like I'm doing 90 pound clean press
squats where I'm holding 90 pounds over
my head,
I could probably do 10 of those,
but I only do for so.
So you don't go to muscle atrophy?
I don't go to failure.
I don't believe in going to failure,
but I think is the best off.
Doing less,
less repetitions,
more often,
so instead of doing one day when you
blow your whole fucking system out and
he'd do
one more bro,
come on one more
the next day you could barely walk,
right?
I think,
and this is what Paul says,
and this is what a lot of people like A.
There's a company called strong first.
What they recommend this like there's a
few people at the front of the line when
it comes to what you would call a
functional fitness functional strength,
right?
And they think that public halls,
greasing the groove,
which means do it more often,
but do it not to failure.
So instead of having one workout every
three days,
we below your body,
I have one workout every day and you
don't blow your body and you'll get
stronger core.
Stimulate,
done,
and not la.
Exactly.
There's no reason in pincher creek where
you can go to failure.
Yeah.
Why would you go to failure in nature?
You wouldn't.
So how does how,
how to how to animals and people and
farmers.
How do they get strong farmers and get
ridiculously fucking strong from going
to failure?
Every day they get ridiculously strong
from consistently taxing their body
moving bails of Hay,
picking up heavy things.
I mean,
you do that consistently.
Make it stronger and stronger.
Yeah.
So that's mostly what I do.
So if I dead lift heavy,
which I rarely do,
that's what I do.
And I only do it for a few rep.
it's
so funny because I did a scene with Matt
Hughes on Kingdom that show that I recur
on and uh,
I kinda grabbed him.
Oh,
he's a gorilla.
I just grabbed them.
I joke around,
I'll wrestle with him and I was a high
school wrestling.
I'm,
I've got my elbows in,
I'm moving in on him and he swatted the
back of my head.
Just kind of grabbed the back of my
head.
He swatter like,
I was like,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
I tried to keep.
I tried to pull my neck up and I was
like,
that's not going to work with Matt
stronger than me.
What a surprise.
You will imagine if fertility with like
a heavyweight.
Then imagine what it's like getting the
back of your neck grabbed by Cain
Velasquez.
I wrestled with Photoshop.
Sometimes it becomes a disaster.
It's so.
It's so bad.
It's ridiculous.
It is.
And then know that,
know this,
that there's guys out there that would
ragdoll hint that it's so weird.
Yeah.
It's so fucking weird.
It gets so great areas if you think
equality exists in nature.
I got news for you to do a sport.
Come wrestle.
I grabbed,
I said to Brendan,
we were about to go do a live show and
speaking of which,
January 18th,
19th,
Vancouver,
20th,
Seattle,
21 a portland.
And uh,
and then we got,
then we got.
Then we got San Francisco,
February ninth and 10th get your
tickets.
But,
but we were about to do a show,
a live show.
And I go,
I look at him and all I said he was just
feeling.
He was just,
he had an energy.
He started pinching at me,
start pinching at me.
I'm like,
Hey,
stop pitching it with giant fucking
palms.
And he's like,
he's jumping around.
And I go,
dude,
I gotta be honest with you,
don't fuck around because I box now a
lot.
And he goes,
you do?
I don't know all bullshit aside.
I jam guys now when they,
when they,
when they got to get something else,
something,
I'll just jam you.
And he goes,
Oh,
what show me?
And I go,
well,
so if we're fighting and I get in you,
and he goes like that and I'm in here.
And he goes,
what if I do this?
And he hits me in the side just he just
slapped my little tummy and the side
like that.
And then he kicks me in the leg just
very lightly.
And I went.
I go,
Oh,
oh,
I don't like this at all.
He goes,
what?
And he goes,
what if I go like this?
And he goes to do a double.
Like He.
All he did was step forward and I'm such
a bitch that,
that,
that little,
those little tabs got me so on edge that
I through my,
instead of sprawling,
naturally I threw my body backwards.
I like the way the way you would do like
when a girl sees a Rockstar,
she goes like the stereotypical,
like in the movies in the fifties.
I throw my body back and I hit my
forearm so hard on the fucking door jam
and I gave myself a deep,
deep forearm bruise that I had to
perform through.
It was tough for me.
You have to know.
I was very funny.
He's a big guy.
You're a smaller guy.
The point is that it is.
I know what it's like to wrestle with a
gorilla.
Yeah,
there's different size people at there.
Now imagine if you're a girl and imagine
that guy is a butcher smile.
I do it all the time.
Then you understand dude,
how rose McCallum fields sexist shit.
Circle motherfucker.
I brought all the way back around.
I was very good at it because you could
do that too.
Rose McGowan.
Tell me he couldn't.
If he kicked her.
Yeah,
I've,
I've never wanted to.
You could fuck rose McGowan up.
Probably.
Could I probably ugly frozen Miguel and
try to kick your ass.
If you're on a beach and you're
competing for coconuts,
she was deciding the you didn't deserve
a coconut.
Oh,
I'd be such a Beta male.
I'd be like,
let me put you into.
I'd be like a cleanser,
a fucking tree for you right now.
How long do you think you'd have to go
before?
You don't have to yell at her if you
were on an island?
That's a very good question.
Rose McGowan on an island.
She'd probably be very.
She'd probably be very effective.
I would have helped.
So I think she's probably one of those
people is probably very focused.
She's got enough anger to drive her
through.
She would decide that the community on
this island is incredibly sexist.
Yeah.
But then she's also really sexual and
she'd be like,
how old are you again?
How many squares in your stomach and why
do you move like a fucking cat?
You think so?
And I was like,
well what about this?
And she'd be like,
that thing can't be real.
And then we'd be off to the racist man.
That's optimistic.
I'm just saying what would happen in my
mind,
I have a feeling it would be like a lot
of yelling and then she would.
She was the only vagina in known
civilization and she would just run your
world.
Well,
listen,
then I let her run my world in a boat
would pull up to shore and be a bunch of
girls that were on a yacht,
jumped away from this Russian mobster,
but then they get lost at sea.
When they landed,
they landed on this island and then all
of a sudden she would change.
Then she'd be your girlfriend.
Then she'd be holding hands with you or
they're talking to you and everything
would change.
Just be one guy knows how to get the
coconuts guy who knows how to fish with
a stick.
It's right.
He knows how to get in there with the
fucking.
It's beer.
Beer.
Yeah.
Fish all the time.
No big deal.
One cloth made the exercise.
Plenty of food here for all of us.
Yes,
and then the girls were just a little
bit cold and they're 10.
We come into your tent and then don't
know how to make fire yet.
Right,
and they'd be like,
what?
What?
All those baby turtles?
I'm like,
well,
we're gonna.
Eat Him.
No.
Their babies just like,
oh,
don't worry if we don't need them.
The fish.
Well anyway,
and then we just fucking munch on some
roads.
Just starts blowing you just while
you're talking to them.
Just mine.
It's mine gets super mine.
There's this,
there's the woman who was a couples
therapist who recommended this to
couples that are having problems.
She.
There's a book that's written and she
wrote a book about it.
It was essentially the idea that when
you feel 100 percent secure in your
relationship,
it's a bad thing for a relationship.
You should always feel like there's a
little danger of your spouse strain
because it keeps you sexually
competitive.
Certainly competitives important.
It's fucking very important to have
those girls or her friend,
those girls who pull up on the island in
the raft listed.
They were roses friends really.
She.
She feels like they're competitors,
but they're really does strengthen the
relationship that you and Rosa.
She needs to know.
I would never cheat on her and I don't
give a fuck about these Russian chicks.
I was now my.
I may fall and stay on,
on a body part here and there because
the end of the day come here.
Hey,
look at me.
I would notice that you're saying that a
coconut falls off your head and kills
you and then that's really fucked up
because then they're just a bunch of
lesbians island and so hot.
And then they come back.
Do you think rose becomes the man then?
Yes.
And then she runs those Russian bitches.
Fucking shaved head.
Yeah.
But she's an actress to Russian horse.
If the hard life,
they've had a hard fucking life,
they've come to stab somebody,
steal livers.
They are emotionally,
uh,
I guess remote maybe for my experiment.
Just really vulnerable.
Yeah.
Brian trying to make their rent.
I had to talk to the picture.
There's a,
there's a funny instagram picture,
like when you see a girls partying a but
you don't see the guys behind them.
Like girls or like instagram,
girls are going off to all these far off
exotic lands and they'd taken selfies.
You don't see the guys that are paying
for that.
Exactly right.
Fat,
disgusting.
Old dudes on yachts.
Exactly.
Those guys are real.
Of course they real.
I'd be one of those guys.
About 10 years.
Do you think.
So keep going.
Well,
do you think you'll ever get to that?
Like driving around in a yacht with a
bunch of prostitutes?
No,
because.
and I've always had,
I've always wanted to a little bit and I
always come back to my set point,
which is you got to be a man of
substance and all that.
It's,
it's why I never dated super like Barbie
doll girls.
Like I would always find it a little
embarrassing.
Maybe the same reason.
I never drove a really fast fancy car.
Uh,
did something about that ostentatious
kind of like,
well,
I don't know what it is.
Like I like,
I know.
No.
Here's a better way of putting it.
I do.
I want to get away from my appetites
out.
I want to be moving toward map updates.
But if you're almost dead,
okay,
if you're 75 years old and you got this
big fat fucking belly filled with carbs,
just giant Buddha like belly.
Yeah.
And you're on,
you know,
200 milligrams of Viagara.
Your ears are ringing.
Jesus Christ.
Dig is just a hard snake in your pants.
You just drinking martinis.
Oh,
and you have $7,000,000,000
in the bank.
What are you going to do?
What are you going to do besides help
the world ba blah,
blah.
Do a lot of humanitarian things.
That's all nice.
But I don't want to be somebody who
chases this sensation.
Are you chasing a sensation or are you
just hitting the gas and headed straight
for the rocks?
No,
no,
because.
Because hitting the gas and wait for the
rest has been done too many times.
I've already felt that.
I've already done it.
I want to move away from it.
There it is.
Hold on,
let me see that when you see this.
All right guys,
remember who owns the boat?
Look at those guys.
Look at the girls.
Hey,
I got news for you.
Some women find that attractive in a
while.
They find the fact that those guys are
going to buy him a bunch of shit.
Yeah.
Don Sterling.
You know,
when he was,
uh,
just had that girl shacked up who's
Byron or Ferrari's and shit before she
recorded him saying racist stuff.
Yeah.
No,
I think chasing,
chasing something that is,
you know,
the idea is to get more away from that
and try to.
Yeah,
no,
I get it.
But it's also a sensation.
I mean that's all it is,
is a fun sensation.
But,
but so as a so as wanting to be like I'm
valued by younger people.
So when,
when men go after young women,
there's one side of it which is you just
want young women are delicious and
beautiful and you know,
their,
their skin and all that.
But I think there's another
psychological thing at play,
which is also the idea.
I'm 60.
I still got it.
She still finds me attractive.
I still can get it up.
I can still pleased her sexually.
I can still hang with the 20 year old.
I can still make her happy.
It's a way of telling yourself,
you're still alive,
that you're still have vitality and all
that shit,
and then there's the third thing which
is,
look at what I've accomplished.
I can afford this shit.
This is another toy along with my car
and my book,
but it's all self affirmation and it's
all at the end of the day,
a manifestation of probably some shit
you haven't worked out,
which is still a feeling of insecurity.
Still a hole you can't fill.
What I hope I can move with that savage
with a Martini in your hand,
a giant hard Dick and you've paid 30
Russian hookers to hang out with you for
a month because you're your doctor found
a blemish on your tumor.
Well,
that's a different.
Some shit going down and it's growing.
Now it starting to cut off the supply to
your.
Your blood.
Yeah.
You're getting blood clots and your feet
go numb at night.
I wonder what I would do it.
Let me think about that because let's
just take that.
I got him a hug.
Give me how much time do I have?
Not much,
uh,
can wake up every morning.
You set the alarm clock for 5:00
AM with creedence clearwater revival,
bad moon rising.
Your Papa Viagara.
Start drinking your guts.
Enormous.
It's definitely,
definitely have cancer.
You know,
you have cancer.
There's probably some internal shit.
Go on it.
But your dick still gets hard and you
still got $7,000,000,000
to burn through.
Your kids are calling you.
You look at the phone like,
fuck you.
You're not getting any of this.
Started a school dude.
Ah,
yeah.
Everyday,
everyday.
The grilling steaks.
Now an onboard chef.
I call every girl Mama and Mama.
Everything is steak.
Steak in the morning.
Who gives a fuck?
Martinis and steak.
Oh yeah.
Martinis steak and a fucking mason jar
filled with Viagara down those fuckers
all day.
Can't hear a thing.
Ears are closed up.
Just a big old gray,
gray
pubic mound.
Yeah.
Your head is constantly aching from the
Viagra flowing through your veins.
But why am I just
good hammer?
I guess I just do some fucking.
You've got a giant fat belly with white
hair all over it.
Fat White in your Dick.
Smells like cheese.
It takes,
it takes miles like old chambers.
Why is not going to happen to me when
the girls are all have those shoes with
the red bottoms.
You know those shoes of the Christian
Louis?
Tell us.
Yeah,
that's the ones because that's where I
get a hard on when I buy gifts for those
girls all have that.
You make them keep those shoes on and
you fuck their mouths when they're lying
on their stomach so that the shoes are
up in the air so you can see the bottom
of the shoes while you bought this for
you about this and then your heart
attacks.
And then when I come
I go,
you're welcome.
And when you die they just throw you
overboard because he's bitches hate you
now.
So like he's dead.
He's finally fucking dead and now even
if you will,
what's in the world?
What do I get?
Anything.
And then nothing.
I don't get it.
They just dragged him by his ankles and
chuck them over the side.
Wow.
The sharks come and eat them.
They want amy.
I'm so full of full of sin.
And just did sharks.
Sharks will eat a shoe.
Well,
not,
not my thing would be turned off by your
sin.
You've.
I think so.
Really?
I want to leave behind a very.
A shredded corpse.
I want people to go.
That's a.
that's a good look in 90 year old right
there.
If there's so much Viagra and the body
of the shark,
it's a boner and the shark is just run
into the ocean with a raging hard on to
get that going through the air.
No sharks fly through the air.
They jump out of the water.
This time it's going to jump out of
water with his Dick.
Rock hard.
Why did they breach the water?
They know why they're having fun.
Yeah.
I would imagine they want to see what
it's like.
There's fucking seals.
Yeah.
They having a good time.
They do it when they're killing things
or they want to do it.
Parasites out their skin.
I heard that's why whales do it.
Maybe.
Interesting.
That makes sense for Wales.
God,
what a bitch that must be there.
Just all those lampreys if just stuck to
you.
Do you know how long they the bowhead
whale lives?
No,
about 250 years.
Do you know how long the Greenland
Shark?
According to carbon dating on their
eyelids?
No.
It's a huge shark to try.
About almost 500 years.
Holy Shit.
Bring that up for a second.
Brand theme.
Greenland.
You know,
they think the greenland shark might
have been what people were seeing in the
loch ness.
Loch ness at one point in history was
connected to the ocean and I think that
that might've been the animal that was
in there.
That's interesting because it would live
500 years.
Although they live in very cold water
polo.
Look at the size of that fucking thing.
Yeah.
Now that is a.
that'll live 500 years apparently.
Four hundred year old greenland.
Shark is the oldest verblah animal
alive.
Whoa.
What a freaky fucking animal that looks
for a hundred years old.
It looks like a stone.
Just think about that.
Before the fucking United States was
founded in 1776.
This was 100 years old and that crazy.
Isn't that fucking crazy?
That's insane.
What a freaky looking animal too.
But they keep finding weirder and
weirder animals.
Two at the bottom of the sea.
They do,
right?
Oh,
it's so amazing.
A tribe in the Amazon,
they just found uncontacted tribe.
The Yanomamo.
Where were they from?
Um,
well,
so I say Yanomamo.
That's a.
isn't that the tribe that Rinella went
hunting with?
And Bolivia.
I,
I know that.
I know that they're the tribe that when
they came back,
the anthropologists in the seventies and
found that the ones that killed the most
men in battle with the ones that sired
the most children.
And when they came back in the seventies
and told the academic world that,
that aggression was inherent and that it
was rewarded by females.
Oh,
you should've seen the politically
correct.
You should have seen what happened in
the seventies.
And that is rearing its head again
today.
The idea that aggression.
Wow,
that's a crazy statement,
man.
So they rejected it in primitive.
People don't know that they attacked.
There's a steven pinker's book,
the blank slate.
They attacked the scientist as policies
that came back.
They attack them personally over it,
tried to ruin their reputations.
Look at how this guy's dressed.
God,
you kidding me right now in 2017,
you know,
it's really amazing.
Isn't it crazy?
Indian Indians.
Why the fuck do they keep calling them
Indians?
I think the thing that's the aborigines
like that,
that comes from that bar in Brazil's.
Well,
it's indigenous in.
Could you say indigenous?
Could you say Indian because of
indigenous or.
No,
but that is so fascinating.
Jamie.
Stop scrolling.
Please go back up to where I was reading
what it was saying there.
The tribe has moved a number of times
since that citing a scout expert and the
regions indigenous groups.
Morrell Mirror morels was on last
Sunday's flight as well as previous
missions in 2008 and 2010.
That also yield.
Did extraordinary images.
These groups changed location every four
years or so.
They move around,
but it's the same group.
How fast is he on Amazon?
Amazon is amazing,
but those fucking people that are
chopping down the trees are closing in
on it.
Sure are less awful.
Look at that guy.
Look at this crazy little hut.
They get the aerial view of the hub
where those people live.
A Thatch Hut Bach to keep the Jaguars
out and look at him,
man.
What is.
What does he got?
Tattoos all over him.
Jamie go larger on that image of him
potty potty.
Wow.
So they're getting pictures from the
air.
He's got some sort of really primitive
knife that's pictures from the air dude.
Yeah,
Yup.
Yeah.
They're flying over these police shit.
Photographer was looking for another
area he was going back for and stumbled
across.
He saw that hut and then Oh,
what's that?
Got in closer and then saw the people
and started taking photos of them.
These people are living like people live
thousands of years ago.
It's amazing.
So that looks like a modern knife to me
now that I'm looking at a deeper,
because if you look below where he's
holding onto it,
there's a wooden handle.
Lower Mckenna.
Yeah,
the.
It looks like a machete.
So how are they uncontacted if they have
a machete,
my chat,
then they got that from someone to look
at this.
The only thing that you see on them
that's modern though.
I mean he's probably holding it up.
Look up modern.
I am.
Motherfucker got a machete.
They look fed and healthy pot pot plots
of corn.
MANIOC and banana surround the cluster
of communal have to be,
again,
probably not.
No know they eat a lot of frogs and
monkeys,
the deed,
everything that they'll.
Dude,
look at that.
They live in the woods.
We look at this equally impressive for
morale.
Murals was the large barrage of arrows
that tribes are fired at the helicopter,
which he took as a healthy site of
resistance.
Wow.
Their messages.
He said those arrows mean leave us in
peace.
Do not disturb.
No,
they mean I'm trying to shoot you bitch.
You know,
leave us in peace.
That's not.
Boy,
you're reading into it too saying.
Get outta here.
You Flying Demon.
Hold on.
Let me see here.
To save cross the border of Peru are
rife with illegal logging crews,
called prospect has and drug
traffickers.
Yeah,
man,
they hire tribes in the past.
I'm sure.
I mean how many of these people are
there?
Go back up to those images.
Jamie,
look at the images of the hut please.
Well yeah,
right there dude.
I want to study.
How many people are that?
I mean that's the.
If you assume that doorway is a human
sized,
how many people live in that?
Twenty.
Thirty.
It's fascinating.
You can learn so much about human nature
by studying them,
but there's no,
there's no way to really study them
though.
That's what's really interesting.
Like would really the real way to study
them live.
We have a drone that they didn't know
was a drone and fly it in there and like
perched on a tree and watch and get as
much data as you can and just live with
them.
Yeah.
But if you live with them you'll be
affecting them because then people,
they would know that you're there.
Like the only way to really study them.
It would be the study them without them
knowing you know,
like look where they are.
Go back there,
go back and all that shit.
Don't change pictures,
go back to that picture,
look at that,
look at the little hut and then look at
where they are,
man.
Fuck.
Look at that.
Nice Green,
massive amount of rain forest and they
just got this clearing
with this little hut.
Man.
That's insane.
That's a view how to live there though.
Like you could do it,
but we.
Everything that we have in our brain
about what is good in life is attached
to civilization.
A Nice house in a good neighborhood.
I want to have cable TV and fast
internet and a microwave food.
If you.
I can get it immediately.
Even if you could get food there if like
they knew.
Like they said they.
They planted bananas.
They planted all this core and they knew
where the food was.
There's plenty.
I'm sure there's a ton of living shit
out there that you can eat.
Right?
So even if you can hunt and gather all
the food you need every single day of
the week,
would you be happy?
Would never performing standup again?
Would you be happy never watching
Netflix again.
And would you be happy with no cell
phone?
Would you be happy with no air flights?
Man Live forever.
Me and my.
My,
my Indian girlfriend.
Yeah.
Who by the way,
it smells like an African prison riot.
How often does that chuck?
Why rains a lot?
It rains a lot and the rains cleanse the
body.
You fucking.
You smelled centric.
Mother's parcel gland.
It's probably smells like a skunk car.
Saw Gland.
They'd probably.
Everyone probably smells like a skunk.
She will.
She probably doesn't bother.
So few of them.
She smokes inside.
Tribes were so small because they
smelled so bad.
They rarely fucked.
And then once people figured out soap
population just exploded.
Like you smell good enough to fuck.
Hey,
sanitation played a huge part in
progress.
I'm serious.
Smelled good enough to be super horny to
fuck one of these people.
They took pictures from the air.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they have to do that is mind blowing.
I know.
And they probably have this haircut and
this is a guy working as bow,
but this is um,
I mean he had to have something to shave
his head,
right.
Body paint.
Obviously to protect from insects
probably.
Yeah.
Maybe you're right.
But the hall right there,
but the hair,
it appears like he's got a razor.
If you can do that to his hair to look
at them or some sort of a knife,
you know the shaved.
I cannot believe this.
I'm fascinated by this.
Oh,
it's incredible.
We're in the stone age.
Look,
intense shit.
That's human beings in the raw.
That's human beings in the raw and we
haven't had.
Haven't come into contact with other
ideas and other cultures and other
people.
And so they stayed that way.
Well,
that's the argument against keeping
dolphins and whales in captivity that
these people who in these are absolutely
100 percent human beings,
right?
We would give them the same rights that
you and I both enjoy.
Those people live like they live
thousands of years ago.
They have a very crude existence that's
not very far removed from workers.
So it's not.
The only thing that's different is
shelter.
They've developed shelter,
which is totally unnecessary for a
dolphin or a killer whale.
So other than that,
you know,
with all the things,
all the metrics that we use to describe
civilization,
I mean they have some tools,
so tools made out of sticks.
I could teach a boy scout how to make a
bow like that.
There are differences.
Sure.
Their mind yet.
But to us looking at that.
Yeah,
I mean you're looking at an incredibly
primitive form of human life in terms of
like what we think of as important.
Like how much of a difference is that
than orcas?
Well here.
Killer.
Well yeah.
You mean you're talking about that exact
example?
Yeah.
That hasn't come into it.
Hasn't had the benefit of,
of,
of sort of sharing ideas,
ideas,
having sex as hunter says.
Yeah,
you're right.
Crazy.
So it's so amazing that it exists
though.
Like I don't know how they could study
it,
but God,
they have to.
They have to.
I mean there's gotta be a way to
infiltrate in some sort of a way and
understand they did a lot of that in
influencing them pop on Guinea.
They did a lot of that.
Yeah.
But again,
with a lot of influence though.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
There's some horrible shit that came out
of New Guinea.
You,
you know about the new,
the semen warriors I sure do.
And and they did a study on how many of
them actually become gay later on.
It's only about five percent.
It has nothing to do with it.
It's really interesting.
But the boys to reach puberty have to
suck the sperm out of the men in the
tribe.
They have to suck them off and take it
in their ass.
Usually it's sucking for about two
years,
two,
three years until they reach puberty.
Said,
yeah,
you can ingest a lot of Dick.
Suck a lot of debt.
I think you have to do that to get
bigger.
Yeah.
You got to do that to become a man.
Someone should just have the rock flying
there.
Look at me.
Boys never sucked a dick once.
Yeah.
And then that was the whole thing would
stop.
That is how it would stop that.
That's exactly how you'd be like,
wait a minute.
Those fucking guys are really strong and
they never talked.
They must ingest the semen of their
elders daily from the age of seven until
he turned 17 to achieve adult male
status.
It's not true to properly mature and
grow strong.
I read that it was a little older than
seven.
Actually.
That's not,
that's not altogether true.
So they'll sure on wikipedia.
What the fuck do you know?
I think that they may be because in the
book a billion wicked thoughts.
I think they start when they're,
uh,
they're gonna reach puberty,
like did like 13 when they started to
show signs and then it helps you get
into.
Because I had read that same thing
though,
that it was younger.
It was seven.
I'm not going to suck.
That guy's.
That guy's cock.
Smells good.
Look at him.
Great.
Look though.
They'll get them great.
Look.
Wow.
That is a crazy look from a guy who you
have to blow.
I mean,
look at how human beings,
they decorate themselves.
It's going to suck my cock.
What's hanging?
You have to suck a grown man's Dick.
It's another thing if he's dressed up
like pokemon,
like what is that paint that he's got on
his face swell up so I can see the lungs
and American horror story.
Look at the pain on his face.
Like what kind of.
He's got this crazy white nose and
bright yellow paint all over his face
with red stripes.
Yeah.
And.
And he's putting in your mouth.
Yeah.
That's a hell of a fro.
It's hard to get over.
Like that's gonna stick with you.
Those images are gonna.
Stick with you.
Average lifespan in Papa New Guinea for
a lot of those tribes is 45 by the way,
because they're sucking dicks all the
time.
That can't be good for eating roots and
food and they're getting
infections.
You're not.
Oh they.
The big myth about,
you know,
and you're in the jungle there.
You can assimilate and you live at.
No,
no shit.
Happens.
Like you get a cut,
it gets infected.
It's immediately.
And homicide is huge.
Homicides,
I think the leading cause of death among
hunter gatherer tribes in Papa New
Guinea because they just get into these
fights with the agenda because when to
get back the dude that made you suck his
dick when you were seven.
No,
he's in your tribe,
sir.
That's just part of it because you're
getting your dick suck now you have to
understand part of the problem.
It's just passed down generation to
generation molestation.
Correct.
That's what's really crazy.
It's almost like child molestation built
into the operating system with their
culture.
Some pedophile said,
you know what guys?
I have,
you know,
I saw a vision.
You think that's one person,
but here's the thing.
Here's the real question.
Like throughout history,
I mean like literally from the beginning
of time people have been molesting young
boys,
like grown men would take young boys
places and the last time logs.
It's socrates,
it's in the.
It's in the dialogue.
So the symposium.
Yeah.
How nuts is that when you,
whenever you consider socrates,
one of the things you have to consider
as a PSA.
Socrates was a pedophile.
He apparently was married and didn't
partake,
but certainly aristotle and Plato and
his students identities didn't and and
his and his contemporaries would talk
about how we have nice boys.
Let's go back and drink some wine.
We'll go,
we'll go eat and kiss some beautiful
boys and then we'll talk some more.
Yeah,
Jesus Christ.
Trust him.
He was never.
He was always.
He famously said,
as philosophers should treat their
appetites,
their body with a quiet contempt.
Learn to let go of your body as you get
older and not not hold onto it because
you're gonna have to let go of it.
So who's the opposite of the dude in the
yacht with a ringing years and the big
fat really well and so much so that when
he got poisoned by the hemlock and his
students were crying,
he said,
you guys,
what are you crying for it?
You're crying over my shell.
I'm going onto something bigger and
you're crying about this broken down
machinery that's going to break down
anyway.
If I taught you nothing,
why did he get poisoned again?
Because he wouldn't essentially,
he would not stop talking.
He was considered to be a heretic in a
way he was,
he was speaking against Athens,
a bet against the elite,
against,
um,
against the gods.
And he was a man of reason,
not so much faith but rather reason.
And so he was somebody who was
considered to be a threat to the power
structure,
a threat to the religion threat to,
and,
you know,
and so socrates was considered a,
essentially an enemy of the state.
He had an opportunity,
they don't want to kill him.
The Greek government said,
get,
you know,
listen,
Hey,
we're condemned to death.
Uh,
I eat,
we're looking the other way.
Get the fuck out of town.
Just be an exile.
And Socrates said,
no,
sorry,
because that would be admitting fault if
you guys want to sin against philosophy,
kill me,
but I'm not going to what I said and I'm
not going to say sorry and I'm not going
to leave because I've lived under these
rules and these laws forever.
And if that's the law of the land that I
will take my punishment,
but you guys are wrong,
but just know this is on you.
Not on me was very powerful,
you know,
there's the apology and there's the,
the,
the you should.
Everybody should read it.
It's fascinating.
Totally different story.
If you talked to them a creepy voice,
that wouldn't be.
It should read it.
And if you want to come and tell you how
he said it said Non Fault of 11,
of 11 under Greg Love Lover Time.
Have you ever contemplated like what it
would be like?
I mean I,
I assume that this is going to be
available and some sort of a simulated
form in virtual reality within you know,
our lives to be able to go and
experience what it would be like to be
inside of a building and watching people
live as if people lived like in that
rain forest or watching people live as
people lived in ancient Greece or
ancient Rome and just trying to
experience what it would be like in our
minds.
This is normal life,
right?
This is normal life being in a building,
electricity,
all that set.
I think it would be so fucking
enlightening if we could just for a
brief moment,
even even if just for a few minutes it
try to experience what life was like
back then and then try to put it into
context.
Well,
I think the big factor would be that
there was so much we didn't know.
For example,
germ theory,
uh,
forget about medical stuff.
Just like when I'm talking about like
the way people look at the world.
Like if you listen to Lenny Bruce today,
it's hard to listen to Lenny Bruce today
because you already know a lot of the
things he's saying and it's not really
so groundbreaking anymore.
But if you listen to it in 1959
nightclub,
you'd be like,
Holy Shit,
this is blowing my mind.
I imagined being in front of socrates,
imagine them being around all these
people that had so little access to
knowledge knew so little about how the
world actually worked or did there.
I Dunno.
So,
so sure they did.
In comparison to what we know today.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
But,
but,
but okay.
I'm actually a saying in the context of
the civilization that existed at the
time,
what kind of a weird world would that
be?
I think the fundamental difference would
be you'd be much.
You'd have a much closer and intimate
relationship with life and death.
Right?
Right.
Because it was always,
yeah,
all the time and you were going to die,
probably have to hide and so you died of
disease that would roll through and the
plague would come and then it would be a
war and all this stuff would happen.
So I think you'd have a more intimate
relationship with death,
but I think actually that when you say
we do have access to more information,
we know more.
Okay.
A as in we know more about the
methodology of like sort of how certain
things work.
We know that there's a shark that list
500 years.
I mean,
I don't know if thinking people back
then less in terms of what it was to be
essentially human and the responsibility
of a human being.
So in other words,
if you really get down to brass tax,
at the end of the day,
you're left with yourself,
you're left with the things you can
conquer within yourself.
You're left with the things you can put
into context about yourself.
You're left with how much self knowledge
at the end of the day when you die,
how well did you get to know yourself?
One of the big values of putting
yourself in in risky situations or
putting yourself into situations where
need to learn something that takes a lot
out of you as you learn about yourself.
And I think the Greeks knew that and
wrote about that as well as anybody
ever.
And I think that they understood like
you read Seneca,
you read socrates and no,
they didn't have the technological
advantages we did,
but they didn't have the ability to get
as close to the rest of the world as we
did.
They had deep,
deep concepts and wrestled with the big
ideas and questions that have never left
us,
that still haunt us.
The idea of what is the difference
between good and evil?
How should I really live my life?
What is the right thing to do and
everybody's telling me to do this and
it's way more convenient,
but what's the answer?
Am I really just my appetites or on my
more than that and if my dignity and my
morality and ethics are compromised,
what I have the courage to stand there
and say I'm going to stay in Greece and
not leave.
Those big human questions are as
relevant today as they were then and if
you really get down to what it's what it
means to be a human being and if you get
down to knowledge,
maybe they may be.
We don't know more than them.
Well first of all,
there's a huge problem with the word we.
Okay,
because like who you talking about?
Are you talking about me?
Are you talking about the greater human
knowledge?
Well,
for sure the greater human knowledge is
far,
far vast,
far more vast,
far more in depth.
We know more about science.
We know more about cells and the
universe and the ocean and everything
there is to be observed as far as
applied knowledge,
like are we living in a wise way?
Well,
we don't really know.
I mean we,
we,
we don't know in comparison to how they
live then because we know we have tails
that were written down and passed.
Generation after generation are honest
understanding of the day to day
existence in terms of what it would be
like to actually be there.
It's very limited.
It's very.
It's also very speculative.
There's a lot of like putting the pieces
together and you know,
that's one of the things that history
professors will do when they're teaching
a class.
They'll paint a picture of what they
believe it was like back then based on
the facts that they,
they can definitely cling to.
But as far as experiencing it,
what was it actually like?
Yeah.
Well I had a really great.
There's a great professor
who,
who teaches this class and the turning
points in European history,
which you can get that teaching company.
He said something really awesome.
He starts to lecture with this.
He said,
I want you guys,
it was the fall of Constantinople,
a city that stood for a thousand years
and walls stood for a thousand years,
and when the Turks came in with this
hundred foot gun and started blasting
the walls,
Jesus Christ,
and then they sold most of the killed a
sack,
the city raped and killed most of the
men and then sold about 150,000
and the slavery,
which means they chained them up and
marched him back to one of their
colonies and sold them on an open
market.
And he said,
and he said,
remember,
this is a city that had stood for a
hundred years.
It was when that then became Istanbul,
became the center of the Ottoman Empire.
And he said,
I want you to think for a second about
what it sounded like to be inside that
city are on that wall.
When it was coming down,
when you knew that walls that it stood
for a thousand years.
We're finally giving way to this new
technology,
which was a giant cannon that it took
them a,
a mile a day to drag,
you know,
and they did it for 100 miles or
something crazy.
So I want you to think these Ottomans
are outside these,
these dudes are going to take no mercy
and they are going to,
they're going to do what they want when
and I want you to,
what did it smell like?
What when they get,
what did it sound like and what was
really going on as you were waiting in
your house and they and they came
through the walls and for the first time
in a thousand years,
your city and everything you knew was
going to be burned,
raped,
killed,
sold into slavery,
and changed.
Think about that shit for a second.
And that was a reality for people.
And that's a fascinating way to teach
history because it brings it down to a
visceral level when you go.
These motherfuckers lived through that.
So I think that the existential
possibility that you and everybody,
you know,
like almost oz,
the Israeli writers,
his mother killed herself and he said,
my mother killed herself because in
Ukraine,
in when,
when she was from Kiev,
I think in one day 25,000
Jews were killed by the Nazis.
And one day he said in her town,
everybody she knew and everybody that
knew those people and everything,
she came from for generation seven
generations wiped away,
all killed.
And now she's in Sun Baked Jerusalem or
Haifa,
wherever it is.
Think about what that was like for a
human being where everything,
you know,
being like,
same thing,
like being a native American,
everything needed,
all the buffaloes killed their bodies.
The hides laced restrict nine.
All the animals that are eating that are
dying.
So all your entire mythology,
Joseph Campbell talks about that all
your whole mythology has been wiped
away.
The buffalo that is the centerpiece of
your mythology or God and all the Egos
and everything else in your God.
Obviously he's not strong enough to stop
this incredibly strong western God.
What does that say about not only your
very existence but the gods?
You've been sacrificing and covering a
lot of territory here?
Brian callen.
You just went through three entire
distance creditors be a distraction.
What it's like to be an ancient person,
not good.
The fact that you could lose everything,
do you have what my was going to get to
something,
but my point was imagine that there's
going to be a civilization one day that
looks back on the primitive nature of us
today with the same sort of like bizarre
reflection that we look back at
socrates,
so we look back on the people that were
on the mayflower.
The.
It's just hard to imagine as we're all
trying to expand our consciousness and
grow as a civilization and we would hope
that with every new president we have
like a a better way of doing things and
our government tightens up and our laws
get better.
That's one of the things that people are
so terrified about with this new
administration that if everyone feels
like it's slipping backwards,
but one day you know,
the give and take the flow,
the ebb and flow of information in 500
years from now when they look back the
way we look at,
you know,
the,
um,
the attack of the Mongols on Gin,
China or Baghdad and any of these
places,
you look back at the destruction that
took place just a few hundred years ago
and the kind of civilization that
existed back then and what would it be
like to be in the felt tense of the
Mongols as they were camped outside of
the gates of the city that they were
going to hurl.
Flaming bodies with catapults at would
sit there,
room's on fire with flaming human
beings.
The fat,
the fat burns really good,
so they would light people on fire,
doused him and kerosene,
light them on fire,
and then launch them through the fucking
air and they would land on buildings and
light them on fire from the outside.
Well,
let me ask you this,
so let's jump ahead to 100 years or
whatever.
So you can live,
you can live 100 years longer than you
are now.
So fucking that robot that looks creep
when 100 percent.
I am 100 percent.
I have fat guy with the white belly on
the uh,
now you want my ears and you won't,
you won't,
you won't have to do because I have
drugs and you'll be all estate shredded
right now.
You'll be a teenager,
the equivalent of a teenager.
What would you do with another 100
years?
Try to get better at life.
What do you mean?
Try to get better at my management of
life might be the entire experience.
Like what,
how much of it is positive?
Not just positive for me but positive
for other people that I interact with.
How much of it,
uh,
how,
how much better have I gotten at a
standup,
at podcasting,
at creating things that,
writing things at expressing myself,
you know,
all those things,
all the things that I'm doing now.
If I had to live five more years,
what would I do in five more years to
try to get better at what I'm doing?
If I had 95 more years.
Other than that,
well,
I'll definitely get better if my body
works.
I'd like to keep doing Jujitsu.
I'd like to keep doing martial arts.
I like to keep working out.
I like Yoga.
It's fun.
It feels good.
You do it how you do it a lot.
Yeah,
I'm doing it three times a week now.
God,
yeah man.
It's um,
I think more things you do,
the better you get at doing things and I
think the better you get at doing
things,
the more of an understanding you have of
yourself and if you're being totally
honest,
the more of an understanding you have of
yourself,
the better you are at managing life.
So I just try to get better at managing
life I can.
And so defining life at managing life as
in knowing where to place your energy,
knowing where to place your energy.
For sure.
I'm knowing,
um,
what,
what something actually means versus how
it makes you feel.
Um,
knowing why things make you feel certain
way while you can,
they could feel totally different in a
different day,
a different circumstance,
like how,
how are you going into things neutral or
you going to things loaded up already
with emotions and with negativity.
And then you immediately react from this
loaded up position instead of from a
neutral position where you can analyze
it and decided that nothing truly has
any meaning other than the meeting that
you give it.
That's the,
that's the book thinking fast and slow
by Daniel Economy.
Yeah.
About,
about.
He won a Nobel Prize in economics.
Really?
Yeah.
And he talks about that.
He did all those experiments,
right?
So,
uh,
just about getting to know how your
body,
how your fast thinking brain reacts and
learning that,
that sort of getting a handle on your
mechanisms and how even the way you hold
your body.
So if you're smiling,
you're going to think something's
actually funnier.
And then if you're frowning,
they had people hold a pencil in their
teeth sideways.
I saw joke.
They thought it was funnier than if they
were holding a pencil,
a deuce with the point.
Oh,
they were in a frown.
They thought it wasn't as funny.
Right,
so or when they were told that take a
test and make come up with sentences out
of the words gray and wrinkled and
sunshine and bald.
They moved to the next test slower
because those words made them think of
old people and so how the language you
use,
how you hold your body,
all those things affect how you are
going to interact with data and stimulus
that you're presented with.
So the state that you are in is going to
influence how you react to something.
I think we all are aware of that though,
right?
You're aware of that?
Yeah.
Like sometimes you're not about myself
up,
you're ramped up.
You don't want to be exposed to bad news
because then you'd be like,
what the fuck?
No,
just compound.
And we all know people who are always
ramped up and they're always having bad
things happen to them and it could be
connected.
Yeah,
don't do.
Do you ever find that you like it really
like I have to guard myself against
negative shit because it'll distract me
from my work?
Oh,
for sure.
Right.
Well,
I mean what if you wanted to,
you could fill your head up everyday
with horror stories that helpful,
not helpful and and also unmanageable.
Like again,
we're talking about the 7 billion people
in the world that you're getting news
from.
You're getting all the events that
happen to 7 billion people and only the
extraordinary ones that fucked up ones
are the ones that are interesting.
The guy who takes that truck and runs it
through the crowd,
those are the ones that are interesting.
Forget about all the people handing out
flowers and inviting people in their
homes for t all those things that are
taking place at the same time,
don't attract our attention.
That's interesting.
So it does become a real problem.
If you want to look at the experiences
of 7 billion people,
you can find a lot of horrific shit,
but if you want to look at the
experience of one person,
you,
Brian Callen,
your interactions are almost entirely
positive.
Know your day is almost entirely filled
with laughter and friendship and fun and
around and getting on stage and
performing and doing podcasts and time
with your family and having a wonderful
time so you can.
You can have a distorted view of the
world by being too aware of the whole
world and then people will tell you,
well,
hey man,
you can't live your life in a fucking
bubble,
man.
No,
that's called life.
Everybody lives in a bubble.
You can't like.
That's why Maryland can go on TV and say
that mixed martial arts isn't art.
Like why is she saying that?
Because that's her bubble in her bubble.
That makes sense.
She could say that if she said that if
we were all backstage at the UFC and she
said that people would be like,
fuck what?
Right?
What the fuck did she just say?
That is so rude.
Why would you say that?
Why would you come here where people
love and worship this and say that?
Why would you come here when people find
the importance in this sport,
in this art form,
and why would you disagree and why would
you downplay it that way?
Sure.
Well,
he did because she's in her bubble.
Everybody's in a fucking bubble course.
There's no way you could be good at
anything you'd have.
You have to create a bubble.
I would argue like because if I want to
write standup and I'm walking down and I
started thinking about the drug cartels
in Mexico and how they kill innocent
people or whatever it might be,
I'm going to get ramped up and I'm going
to go,
what would I do in that situation?
I'm going to get full of fear and I'm
not going to be thinking about what I
got to thinking about,
which is,
you know,
whatever it might be.
Or maybe I can use that in my stuff,
but I find I have to really guard
against unhelpful think you should.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's one of the reasons why I
refuse to go down all these God damn
conspiracy holes that everybody wants
you to go down and read this.
Read that like I don't want to.
Don't want.
Man.
You should know.
You should know about it.
No,
no,
I shouldn't.
I can't know about everything.
I fucking can't.
There's not enough time in the day,
you know,
and I don't know who killed Kennedy,
but it was a long time ago and I'm done.
Yeah,
I'm done.
I don't want to look into it anymore.
Maybe one day I'll change my mind,
but you can't say that someone has to go
down.
These roads are.
You have to pay attention to this.
Oh,
you have to pay attention to my work to
be too much.
If you want to find out all the threats
that isis poses to civilization,
cheeses,
fucking Christ.
How much time do you have?
Do you want to find out how dangerous
Putin really is?
Boy,
how much fucking time do you have?
How much time do you have?
Do you want to find out all the
different potential gender roles that
people play and gender identities that
people cling to and all the different
types of sexuality that exists and
perversion and how many people jerk off
on feet and it's not any time.
It's high tech procrastination.
If you do think that way,
it keeps you away from yourself,
but they're putting things a little
scary.
It's all scary.
Do we have more about that?
Do we know more about whether he has any
black shit?
I don't.
I don't think.
No,
no,
no.
That came that whole story about him
hiring.
Yes.
That's fake news.
There you go.
And it came out of a fucking post on
what was it on was.
Unfortunately I fell for it.
I just felt for.
But this is the thing that's the world
we live in.
You know,
this is this fake news is a real problem
and it's even bigger problem because
what we consider to be legitimate news
sources talk about it as a rumor.
This is the rumor,
so they don't even.
Some say unsubstantiated reports.
You can't say that.
You can't even say that.
I know because I,
the Wall Street Journal said this has
not been substantiated,
but those fucks and now I'm like,
wait a minute.
They are dying every day.
The entire system of mainstream media is
slowly eroding to the Internet,
but with this is we need reliable
sources.
We do,
we do,
but we need someone who's going to be
reliably do it on the Internet and I
don't think that's impossible.
I think we find someone who's truly
absolutely 100 percent ethical.
They're out there and objective and also
someone who is not just going to go
after fantastic stories because they
make big ratings,
but someone who goes after stories that
are actually important because their
significant events and issues and does
it in an objective way.
Everything's editorialized.
All these things that people realize
this fake.
It's fake.
The golden showers and all that shit
sounded like bullshit.
It sounds too obvious.
Oh,
he.
He likes to Hire Hookers to pee on the
bed that Obama slept on.
Get out of here.
Man.
That seems so corny.
Yeah,
but if he did do it,
I wouldn't be shocked.
I wouldn't be surprised if he was in
Russia and you know that he had some
gorgeous women with them and they have
video of it that I wouldn't be surprised
by the way.
I don't care.
I mean either.
I don't care if he hired someone to pee
on the bed.
I don't care if he thinks it's funny to
hire someone to pee on the bed.
I don't think that that makes him a bad
person.
I think he's a rich guy who does fucked
up shit sometimes because he's a rich
guy.
Yeah.
I mean I wouldn't even get them to smoke
or drink,
so maybe that's how he gets his rocks
off.
Yeah.
You know what?
Maybe cut a lot of ground.
Covered a lot of talking.
I'm going to wrap this up.
So mixed metal arts.
I liked the new name.
Great.
Starting in episode two.
Oh,
700 miles is fantastic to hear.
Thanks for.
Thanks for turning me onto him and get
me on the podcast.
He was wonderful and fighter and the kid
t fat k.com.
Come see us in there guys doing live
shows.
I'll be in,
uh,
in Austin at cap cities.
February one,
two,
three,
four.
I love Shit.
Get your ticket clubs.
Cap City's got.
Damn it.
Austin,
Texas one through four.
I can't wait.
Beautiful.
Doing podcasts there to fuck.
Yeah,
you will.
All right.
We're done for today.
See a kid's always a good fucking time.